I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies.
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了“终极办公室重温”播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有当事两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。
Hello Angela. Hi Jenna. We are here. We are surrounded by lamps. Office Ladies. Hello, Angela. Hi, Jenna. We are here. We are surrounded by lamps. So both of us have some progressive eye sight issues. Problems, yes.
你好，安吉拉。嗨，珍娜。我们到了。我们被台灯包围了。办公室女士。你好，安吉拉。嗨，珍娜。我们到了。我们被台灯包围了。所以我们俩都有一些老花眼问题。视力问题，是的。
Deteriorating eyesight. And we both just got new glasses. But here's the thing we need, lots of light. I need a well-lit room. I am that person at a restaurant now who is holding the little votive candle. Over the menu. Yeah, that's right. And using your iPhone light.
视力退化。而且我们俩刚配了新眼镜。但问题是，我们需要大量的光线。我需要一个光线充足的房间。我现在就是那种在餐厅里拿着一个小蜡烛杯放在菜单上的人。对着菜单。对，没错。还会用你的iPhone手光。
I try not to use the iPhone light because it's just so incredibly embarrassing, but it sometimes comes to that. Oh, I've let it go. I'm iPhone light. I would like to point this out, and maybe I shouldn't put it in our stories. We have an addition to the overhead light that comes in this room, right? There's track lighting, there's all these bulbs. We have brought in lamps. I'm talking floor lamps, guys, like that you see at Target, you know, the floor lamps. We have one, two, three, four, four around us right now,
我尽量不用iPhone手电筒，因为它实在太尴尬了，但有时也没办法。哦，我已经不在乎了。我就是iPhone手电筒。我要指出这一点，也许我不该把它放到我们的故事里。除了这个房间里的顶灯之外，我们还有一个附加照明，对吧？有轨道灯，有各种灯泡。我们还搬来了台灯。我说的是落地灯，各位，就像你在Target看到的那种，你知道的，落地灯。我们周围现在有一个、两个、三个、四个，四个落地灯，
four floor lamps. We're ladies who love lamps. We're the lamp ladies. We're the lamp ladies. And we're here today to talk to you about Scott's Tots. Season six, episode 12, written by Lee Eisenberg and Gene Stupnitsky and directed by BJ Novak. Our very own BJ Novak.
四个落地灯。我们是喜欢灯光的女士。我们是灯光女士。我们是灯光女士。我们今天来到这里，和大家聊聊“斯科特的 Tots”。第六季第 12 集，由李·艾森伯格和吉恩·斯图普尼斯基编剧，BJ·诺瓦克导演。我们亲爱的 BJ·诺瓦克。
Yeah. Here's a summary. It's time for Michael to face the music on an empty promise that he made 10 years ago. Ugh. Here's the promise. He told 15 elementary school students that when they graduated from high school, he would pay their college tuition. Because he believed he would be a millionaire by that time.
是的。这是一个剧情梗概。迈克尔是时候为他 10 年前许下的一个空头支票付出代价了。呃。承诺是这样的。他曾告诉 15 名小学生，等他们高中毕业时，他会支付他们的大学学费。因为他相信到那时自己会成为百万富翁。
But he's not. And he can't do it. Nope. So he's going to have to go to their school and tell them today. In person. Meanwhile, Dwight hatches a diabolical plan to try and get Jim fired. He literally calls it a diabolical plan. Yep.
但他没有。而且他付不起。没错。所以他今天必须去他们的学校告诉他们。当面说。与此同时，德怀特策划了一个恶毒的计划，试图让吉姆被解雇。他 literalmente 称之为恶毒计划。是的。
He printed out a little outline of his plan. So, as many of you know, this episode is considered the cringiest. Yeah, Jen and I were talking as we prepped for this episode we both went online. There are so many articles that list the cringiest moments or cringiest episodes of The Office and Scott's Tot pretty much makes number one on almost all the lists. Well, we're very excited today because we are interviewing the director of this episode, BJ Novak. We're going to ask him all about it.
他还打印了一份他计划的大纲。正如大家所知，这一集被认为是全剧最令人脚趾抠地的。对，我和珍娜在筹备这一集时聊天，我们都上网查了。有那么多文章列出了《办公室》中最令人尴尬或脚趾抠地的时刻或剧集，“斯科特的 Tots”几乎在所有榜单上都高居榜首。好了，我们今天非常兴奋，因为我们要采访这一集的导演 BJ·诺瓦克。我们要向他打听所有内幕。
B.J., hello. Welcome to Office Ladies. Thank you. Welcome back, I've been on. Wait, are we starting with some BJ Sass? I think we just started with Sass already. I love it. Whoa, whoa, whoa, that's not my brand.
BJ，你好。欢迎来到“办公室女士”。谢谢。欢迎回来，我来过。等等，我们这是要开始一波 BJ 式的毒舌了吗？我觉得我们已经开始毒舌了。我喜欢。哇，哇，哇，这不是我的风格。
It's the Ryan brand. It's the Ryan sass coming through. Yes, welcome back to Office Ladies. Is this your third? Second. Second. You have no memory of any of this. Do I know you?
这是瑞安的风格。瑞安式的毒舌出现了。是的，欢迎回到“办公室女士”。这是你的第三次？第二次。你对这一切完全没印象了。我认识你吗？
Have we met? Who are you? How'd you get into Zoom? You're on my IMDB right now. It's like, oh wow. I guess I worked with him. Okay. BJ, thanks so much for being here. Yeah, I keep staring at you two. It's pretty cool. I'm like, are they the same people?
我们见过吗？你是谁？你是怎么进到 Zoom 里的？你现在就在我的 IMDB 页面上。就好像，哦，哇。我猜我跟他合作过。好吧。BJ，非常感谢你能来。对，我一直盯着你们两个看。这挺酷的。我就想，她们还是原来那两个人吗？
I know I did this before, but. Well, we're the same, just slightly rounder. Yeah. I was talking to Brian Baumgartner for the first time in forever, not in person. And I was like, when I see him, is he even Brian to me anymore? Is it just like, Kevin? Like it's this weird blur when it's been so long. Well, I totally get that though, because Jen and I also live in this weird kind of surreal place where we see you every week.
我知道我以前做过这个，但是。嗯，我们还是原来那样，只是稍微圆润了一点。对。我生平第一次和布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳说话，不是当面。然后我就想，当我见到他时，他对我来说还是布赖恩吗？还是就像凯文那样？当时间过去这么久，这一切都变得模糊不清了。嗯，我完全理解这一点，因为我和珍娜也生活在那种奇怪的超现实世界里，我们每周都能见到你。
Every week, but we- Oh, because you rewatch. Yeah. And we rewatch multiple times as we do research and stuff. So we'll watch each episode three times at least, you know? Wow. Yeah. And it's... You're in that phase, your character's in that phase right now where like every week you're doing something weird like wearing a fedora or glasses or like a weird patterned vest. Yes, that's what you do when you don't know what to do with the character.
每周都见，但是我们——哦，因为你们在重温。对。而且我们在做研究的时候会反复重温很多次。所以每一集我们至少会看三遍，你知道的？哇。对。而且……你正处于那个阶段，你的角色现在正处于那种阶段，每周你都在做一些奇怪的事情，比如戴着呢帽、眼镜或者穿着一件奇怪图案的马甲。对，这就是当你不知道该拿这个角色怎么办时会做的事情。
Or like a weird patterned vest. Yes, that's what you do when you don't know what to do with the character. But you guys are living in our brains in this like, this predated place, you know? Obviously, you are the DNA of you enjoy watching the stuff you've done. Yeah. And I'll say this, my lore of the show before we started this rewatch was that it was only good for a few seasons. And then it was like meh. I know. We were really snobby about it.
或者像一件奇怪图案的马甲。对，这就是当你不知道该拿这个角色怎么办时会做的事情。但你们活在我们的脑海里，在这个过去的时代，你知道吗？显然，你们身上带有享受自己做过的事情的基因。是的。我要这么说，在我们开始这次重温之前，我对这部剧的了解是它只有前几季好看。然后就变得一般般了。我知道。我们对此真的很自命不凡。
And it's not true. I thought season three, I was like, this show is over. But it is not true at all. We're in the middle of season six. We're like perusing right into season seven. And it is a pleasure and a joy to watch. There were episodes where I thought, oh, that I remember when we were doing them
但事实并非如此。我当时觉得第三季的时候，我就想，这部剧完了。但事实根本不是这样。我们现在看到第六季中期了。我们马上就要进入第七季了。观看它是一种纯粹的享受和快乐。有些剧集我曾经想过，哦，我记得我们在拍的时候
that we were like, oh, so broad and blah. And Jen and I are watching them and laughing our asses off. Yeah, like mafia. I was like, when we shot mafia, I was like, what has happened to us? Why is Ed dressed as a mechanic? It is just, it's amazing. Like, there's just nothing wrong with it.
我们当时觉得，哦，太肤浅了，太无聊了。结果我和珍娜看着它们，笑得前仰后合。对，就像黑手党那一集。我当时就想，我们在拍《黑手党》的时候，我就想，我们怎么了？为什么埃德穿得像个机械师？这简直太棒了。就好像，它没有任何毛病。
I mean, some of the bigger swings are more clear. Why you doubt them like Kevin and the chili. Did we talk about Mindy and I were like, no, this is the dumbest. I was like, okay, the cold open Kevin makes chili. He loves it. He walks up, he spills the chili. And we're like, that's the joke. We're like this intellectual show and it's like a classic.
我是说，其中一些比较大的转折更明显。为什么你会怀疑它们，比如凯文和他的辣椒。我们讨论过吗？我和明迪当时都觉得，不，这是最蠢的。我当时就想，好吧，开场白是凯文做辣椒。他太喜欢了。他走过来，把辣椒洒了。然后我们就想，这就是笑话。我们觉得这是一部很知客的剧，而这就好比一个经典。
Yeah. It's also like when you're in a school play, when you're a kid and your parents see Saturday night or Friday night, and you're like, it was so much better Saturday. The parents are like, I know you think that. To me, it's just you in a play. Yeah. I feel like to me, it's just you in a play. Okay? And I feel like to fans, it's like, okay,
是的。这也就像当你还是个孩子的时候参加学校的话剧演出，你的父母在周六或周五晚上来看，然后你会说，周六那场好得多。父母就会说，我知道你是这么想的。对我和来说，那不过就是你在演一出戏。是的。我觉得对我来说，那不过就是你在演一出戏。好吧？我觉得对于粉丝来说，这就好比，好吧，
but it's Jim and Pam, it's still The Office, guys. I'm sorry that season six wasn't season, it's very funny, I get it. It's the same show. Oh, that's really good, actually. That's so true. It's so true. Thank you for coming on today.
但那是吉姆和帕姆，这依然是《办公室》，伙计们。我很抱歉第六季不是某一季，这真的很好笑，我懂。这就是同一部剧。哦，这真的很棒，实际上。太真实了。太真实了。谢谢你今天能来。
Oh, I love it. So that we could talk about Scott's Tots, which you directed. It was your directorial debut of The Office. Of anything, yeah. Now, had you not directed a webisodes before this? Oh, that's true. I did the webisodes. Yeah. But you know, the first substantial thing. Do you guys remember anything about the show? The two of you? The...
哦，我太喜欢了。这样我们就可以聊聊《斯科特的 Tots》了，这一集是你导演的。这是你对《办公室》的导演首秀。也是任何作品的首秀，是的。现在，在此之前你没有导演过网络短剧吗？哦，对哦。我拍过网络短剧。是的。但你知道的，第一部实质性的作品。你们俩还记得关于这部剧的任何事情吗？你们两个？那个……
Hand-me-j. Angela, you want to just handle this on your own? I mean, I think you got this. I got this. Well, we have some stats to throw at you about some reviews of Scott's Tots. We do. Just so we get clear, did you bring me on to answer for Scott's Tots? No. Apologize?
Hand-me-j。安吉拉，你想自己处理这个吗？我是说，我觉得你行。我行。好吧，我们有一些关于《斯科特的 Tots》评价的数据要抛给你。我们确实有。为了搞清楚，你把我请来是为了替《斯科特的 Tots》辩护吗？不。道歉吗？
No, no, no. Okay, okay. No, no, no. Because I know some of this, but please, let's refresh. No, not at all, not at all. Okay, what are they saying? Scott's Tots is widely referred to as the cringiest episode of The Office. The majority of our fan questions that we got for this episode were not questions at all.
不，不，不。好吧，好吧。不，不，不。因为我知道一些情况，但请吧，让我们复习一下。完全没有，完全没有。好吧，他们都说了什么？《斯科特的 Tots》被普遍称为《办公室》中最令人尴尬的一集。我们为这一集收到的绝大多数粉丝提问根本算不上问题。
They were actually just comments on how cringey and uncomfortable it is for people to watch this show, how a lot of people skip it when they do a re-watch of the show. We found an article on Bustle.com that was titled this, the scientific reason office fans really can't watch Scott's Tots no matter how hard they try. Oh, there's a whole article. There's a doctor and everything. Yes, Dr. Judith Orloff is the author of the Empath Survival Guide, and she said, quote,
它们实际上只是评论，关于看这一集对人们来说有多尴尬、多不舒服，很多人在重温这部剧时都会跳过这一集。我们在 Bustle.com 上找到了一篇文章，标题是这样的：为什么办公室粉丝无论如何努力都真的无法观看《斯科特的 Tots》的科学原因。哦，还有整整一篇文章。里面甚至还有一位医生。是的，朱迪丝·奥洛夫博士是《共情者生存指南》的作者，她说道，引述：
fans might very well avoid this episode to avoid something painful that's hard to face in themselves. There is a subreddit with almost 17,000 subscribers that is titled, cannot watch Scott's Tots, and it is still regularly updated. This was my favorite. What? One person on this subreddit said that Scott's Tots is like the moment Toby put his hand
粉丝们很可能会避开这一集，以逃避某些痛苦且难以直面自己内心的东西。有一个拥有近 17,000 名订阅者的子版块，标题是“无法观看斯科特的 Tots”，而且它仍然定期更新。这是我最喜欢的一个。什么？这个子版块上的一个人说，《斯科特的 Tots》就像托比把手放在
on Pam's knee but stretched out for a whole episode. BJ, at the time, did you know? Did you know that you were directing what would become the cringiest episode of The Office? I had no idea. It seemed great. I was assigned the script, loved it. It was only much later.
帕姆膝盖上那个时刻，但被拉长成了整整一集。BJ，当时你知道吗？你知道你正在导演一集将成为《办公室》中最令人尴尬的一集吗？我完全不知道。感觉挺好的。我分配到了这个剧本，很喜欢它。直到很久以后我才知道。
I think it's a sign of how deep into the show I was or we all were, that we did not have a foot in the real world. Not that it was an unrealistic episode, just that that's exactly what Michael would do, that's exactly what Michael would do, that's exactly what Michael would feel. I also think that, you know, we can talk about it creatively. It makes a lot of sense to me. I don't know if people are responding to...
我想这说明了我或者我们所有人对这部剧的投入有多深，以至于我们在现实世界中没有立足之地。并不是说这不是一集不现实的剧，而是迈克尔绝对会这么做，迈克尔绝对会这么做，迈克尔也绝对会有这种感受。我也认为，你知道的，我们可以从创作角度来讨论它。这对我来说很有意义。我不知道人们是不是在回应……
It seems like no one's responding to, it's a bad episode or it's Michael wouldn't do that. It's more just like, that's so hard to watch. So it is consistent, I think, with the show. So to us, it just made sense. It was consistent. I don't remember anyone saying, you can't do this. But to me, I mean, it is heartbreaking
似乎没有人认为这是一集烂剧或者迈克尔不会这么做。更多的是觉得，这一集太难看了。所以我想这与这部剧是一致的。所以对我们来说，这是顺理成章的。我不记得有人说过，你不能这么做。但对我来说，它是令人心碎的，
from both the kid's perspective, sure, but from Michael's perspective, which is the one you just happened to be following in the office, which is that he, to me, the key to the episode was that Michael was so sure that he would be successful, that he could make this promise. Yeah. Yeah. He so believed in himself.
从孩子们的角度来看，当然如此，但从迈克尔的角度来看，也就是你在办公室里碰巧一直在关注的那个角度，也就是他——对我来说，这一集的关键在于迈克尔是如此确信自己会成功，他才会许下这个承诺。是的。是的。他太相信自己了。
Yes. It's not, to me, it's not about the lie. It's not about what ended up being a lie or a broken promise. He got carried away with his generosity, his belief in himself. So to me, it was a very... Maybe this is what people can do about it. It's a very, very lovable version of Michael Scott, as well as a heartbreaking version of Michael Scott. It's the whole series in an incredibly distilled uncomfortable way
是的。对我和来说，这无关谎言。这与最终变成谎言或破裂的承诺无关。他被自己的慷慨和对自己坚定的信仰冲昏了头脑。所以对我来说，这是一个非常……也许这就是人们对它的看法。这是一个非常非常可爱的迈克尔·斯科特版本，同时也是一个令人心碎的迈克尔·斯科特版本。从迈克尔·斯科特的角度来看，它是整部剧集以一种极其精炼、令人不适的方式的浓缩，
from the Michael Scott point of view, when you look at it like that. To me, it's maybe one of the most Michael things Michael has ever done. 100 percent. I love the line so much. I felt like it was everything you need to know about Michael when he says, I've made some empty promises in my life, but hands down, that was the most generous.
当你这样看待它的时候。对我来说，这可能是迈克尔做过的最具迈克尔风格的事情之一。百分之百。我太喜欢这句台词了。我觉得这就是你需要了解关于迈克尔的一切，当他说：“我一生中许下过一些空头支票，但毫无疑问，那是最大方的一次。”
That line is like so perfect. BJ, I made a list because there are a bunch of articles that list the cringiest episodes of The Office. Get ready. You wrote most of them. They're Prince Family Paper, Diversity Day, Sexual Harassment, and Chair Model, all of which you wrote. Yes.
这句台词简直太完美了。BJ，我列了个清单，因为有很多文章列出了《办公室》中最令人尴尬的剧集。做好准备。大部分都是你写的。它们是《普林斯家族纸业》、《多元化日》、《性骚扰》和《椅子模特》，这些全都是你写的。是的。
Yes. Chair Model, you remember Chair Model, where Michael falls in love with a woman in a magazine and finds out she's died. And he is as if like he lost his wife for 50 years. Paul Lieberstein wrote a lot. I love that episode. Paul is the source of the darkness on that one. And look, I wrote a lot of very joyous stuff too.
是的。椅子模特，你还记得《椅子模特》吗？迈克尔爱上了一个杂志上的女人，然后发现她去世了。他的悲伤就好像他失去了妻子 50 年一样。保罗·利伯斯坦写了很多。我太喜欢那一集了。保罗是那一集中黑暗元素的源头。听着，我也写了很多非常欢乐的东西。
I wrote a lot of The Jim and Pam. I wrote Threat Level Midnight, which is a very joyful episode. So I'm not, it's not like I'm the Prince of Darkness on the show. And also, look, there were what? How many hundred episodes? I worked on like, you know, more than half of them. So it's not, I'm not just this, this dark figure. I'm proud of it. I'm less dark now though, because again, I do hear this and I do go, Oh my god, like how was I capable of some of this? Like especially when I when I see Ryan Howard, I'm like, Oh my god, like I don't see any villain like this. Here's the Mashable article that comes out after this episode. BJ Novak, Prince of Darkness of the Office.
我写了很多吉姆和帕姆的戏。我写了《午夜威胁级别》，这是一集非常欢乐的剧集。所以我也不是，我不是这部剧里的黑暗王子。而且，听着，当时有几集？好几百集呢？我参与了大概，你知道的，超过一半的剧集。所以我不只是一个，这个黑暗的人物。我为此感到骄傲。不过我现在没那么黑暗了，因为再说一次，当我听到这些评价时，我确实会想，“哦，天哪，我以前怎么能做出其中一些事情？”尤其是当我看到瑞安·霍华德的时候，我会想，“哦，天哪，我怎么没看出他是个恶棍。”这是这一集播出后 Mashable 网站发表的文章。BJ·诺瓦克，《办公室》的黑暗王子。
Yeah. No, BJ, we love, like, my god. No, I think the dark is important. And I think that I remember after season one, which was six episodes, and I think all of them ended pretty darkly, right? The pilot, hot girl, I mean, we had that nice moment at the end of diversity, but the pilot diversity day, hot girl, healthcare,
对。不，BJ，我们很喜欢，天哪。不，我认为黑暗元素很重要。而且我认为我记得在第一季之后，一共六季，我觉得每一集的结局都挺黑暗的，对吧？试播集，辣妹，我是说我们在《多元化日》结尾有一个美好的时刻，但试播集、多元化日、辣妹、医疗保健，
extremely dark. Basketball, I don't remember. Office Olympics and basketball maybe were a little more positive endings. But, you know, we had sort of a big group meeting that Greg led about, okay, what are we going to do differently in season two? And there was a lot different. And one of them was three out of four endings should be positive.
极其黑暗。篮球赛，我不记得了。办公室奥运会和篮球赛的结局可能稍微更积极一些。但是，你知道的，我们开过一个由格雷格主持的大型团体会议，讨论我们在第二季中要做什么不同的改变？结果有很多不同。其中之一就是四分之三的结局应该是积极的。
And then one is just for us, meaning Paul. He was like, we're not going to totally sell out. But the British had ended dark every time, more or less. And we had been ending dark every time, more or less. And so the new thing was, you know, so I guess Scott's Tots was definitely one of those four. One for us. Yeah. But again, I do think it's an interesting, it is a deep, interesting one.
然后其中一个是专门为我们准备的，也就是保罗。他当时的意思是，我们不会彻底妥协。但英国原版的结局每次都比较黑暗。而我们的结局也每次都比较黑暗。所以新的改变是，好吧，我想《斯科特的 Tots》绝对是那四分之之一。属于我们的一集。对。但再说一次，我认为这是一个有趣的、深刻的有趣故事。
It's not that it's not part of the canon. It is very difficult, I agree. I think, though, it is Michael. It's honestly Michael trying to do something good, believing in himself, knowing. Well, I don't think he knows he's going to fall short. Well, look how much he believes in Pam and her art. I know.
并不是说它不属于正片。这确实非常困难，我承认。不过，我认为这就是迈克尔。老实说，这就是迈克尔在试图做一件好事，相信自己，知道……好吧，我不认为他知道自己会失败。好吧，看看他对帕姆和她的艺术有多么坚信。我知道。
He is such a believer. He is. And so his belief got ahead of him. And this is by far, exactly like the line you quoted, this is the biggest consequence of all of his belief. Now we should remind people or I should remind people, I wish I had. I admire it. I did not write the episode. This was a Lee Eisenberg and Gene Sibnitsky episode. And I hope it doesn't sound like I'm disowning it either,
他是一个坚定的信仰者。他确实是。所以他的信念超前了。而这可以说是他所有信念带来的最大后果。现在我们应该提醒大家，或者我应该提醒大家，我希望我有。我很佩惜。我并没有写这一集。这是李·艾森伯格和吉恩·西布尼斯基的一集。我希望这听起来不像是我想跟它撇清关系，
because I know we talked about some of you who are uncomfortable. You know, these are two of, I think, the most brilliant writers, the backbone of the show, when a lot of the original staff was burnt out. These guys took the ball and a lot of the sort of center, central seasons of the, of the office that people, that were really humming, that was Lee and Gene,
因为我知道我们聊过，你们有些人会觉得不舒服。你知道，这两位我认为是最才华横溢的编剧，是这部剧的中流砥柱，当许多元老级员工都精疲力竭时。这两个人挑起了大梁，而且《办公室》中许多核心季的内容，那些真正运转良好的部分，都是李和吉恩写的，
were just turning out scripts and revising scripts they're not even credited for. So those guys were really an incredible backstop for that. But, you know, the But look, Gene in particular, I think is the best one-liner writer in office history. He's the one who wrote, I'm not superstitious, but I'm a little stitious. So I would guess he wrote that line.
他们不断产出剧本，甚至修改那些他们连署名都没有的剧本。所以这些人真的是这方面不可思议的后盾。但是，你知道，特别是吉恩，我认为他是《办公室》历史上最棒的单行台词写手。就是他写了那句：“我不是迷信，但我有点迷信。”所以我猜那句台词是他写的。
But yeah, maybe we're getting a little off track, but that is this incredible distillation of why we love Michael so much and why he's made everyone's life so impossibly difficult, which is sort of the heart and the comedy of the series. But it's not usually that intense, you know? Well, what was it like, BJ, you talked about, you know, Lee and Gene as the writers, but you went from writing to directing on The Office. And what was was it like, BJ, you talked about, you know, Lee and Jean as the writers, but you went from writing to directing on The Office.
但是，是的，也许我们有点跑题了，但这正是我们为什么如此深爱迈克尔，以及为什么他把每个人的生活都搞得如此难以置信地艰难的绝妙浓缩，这也是本剧的核心和喜剧所在。但它通常没有那么激烈，你知道吗？那么，BJ，你谈到了，你知道的，李和吉恩作为编剧，但你从《办公室》的编剧转行成了导演。从编剧室到成为该剧的导演，这种转变是什么体验？
And what was that shift like to go from the writer's room to being the director of the episode? It felt very intuitive. I took it very seriously, but I overprepared. I don't think I did any better on the first one than I did on the fifth one that I did. But I think that it's just very interesting what is required to leap from writer to director and I think to an extent actor to director is so much the confidence to picture yourself saying action and cut. Did you get any advice from anyone before you
从编剧室到成为这一集的导演，这种转变是怎样的？感觉非常直观。我非常认真对待，但我准备过度了。我不认为我拍的第一集比我拍的第五集做得更好。但我认为，从编剧跨越到导演需要具备什么能力，这一点非常有趣，而且我认为演员跨越到导演在某种程度上也是如此，那就是有信心想象自己说出“Action”和“Cut”。你在开始执导之前从任何人那里得到过建议吗？
started directing? Yes, I got the best advice and I pass it on to anyone who directs. So the first piece of advice I got, first of all, it's good advice in general, ask everyone for advice. People love giving advice. So anytime you wish you had advice and you're shy, I ask them, people will talk your ear off.
是的，我得到了最好的建议，我把它传授给任何当导演的人。所以我得到的第一个建议，首先，总的来说这是一个好建议：向所有人征求建议。人们喜欢给建议。所以任何时候你希望得到建议却又害羞时，去问他们，人们会跟你聊个没完。
So I asked everybody, what's your advice for directing? And I should also, we should clarify directing an ongoing TV show is incredibly different. The actors know the characters, the writers know the story, the directors, photography and cameramen know how to shoot it. If you just stand there and nicely and intuitively and confidently ask everyone, how would you shoot this? How would you schedule this? Did that feel good to you? You're fine. Because the show is set in the pilot stage,
所以我问了所有人，你对当导演有什么建议？而且我也应该，我们应该澄清一下，导演一部正在热播的电视剧是完全不同的。演员了解角色，编剧了解故事，摄影指导和摄像师知道如何拍摄。如果你只是站在那里，友好、直观、自信地问每个人，你会怎么拍这个？你会怎么安排这个时间表？你觉得这样感觉好吗？你就没事了。因为这部剧在试播阶段就已经定型了，
whereas a movie or a limited series, which is essentially like a long movie, you have to establish, is there music in the show? Is this a very colorful show? Is this a little bit of a campy wink wink show? Is it super dead pan? Like you have to establish all these things.
而电影或限定剧（本质上就像一部长电影）你必须确定，这部剧里有音乐吗？这是一部色彩非常丰富的剧吗？这是一部带点坎普风、带有某种暗示的剧吗？它是超级冷面滑稽风吗？就像你必须确立所有这些事情。
But on an ongoing show, it's kind of like, I look, I took it super seriously because it's an amazing first step, but it's not nearly as hard, you know, coming into an ongoing show. Okay. The advice I got from Randall Einhorn, our long time director of photography
但在一部正在播出的剧里，有点像——听着，我极其认真地对待它，因为这是一个很棒的第一步，但进入一部正在播出的剧，远没有那么难，你知道的。好吧。我从兰德尔·埃因霍恩那里得到的建议，他是我们长期的摄影指导，
and later our most prolific director on the show, I said, you have advice? He said, yes. Direct the cameras like they're actors. I said, what do you mean? He said, you'd never tell an actor, shout this line and cut it off after three seconds, right? You tell them why. So you never tell
后来成为我们剧中最最高产的导演，我说，你有什么建议吗？他说，有。像对待演员一样导演摄像机。我说，这是什么意思？他说，你永远不会对演员说，大喊这句台词并在三秒钟后切断，对吧？你会告诉他们为什么。所以你永远不会对
the camera, swing to the left on this line and punch in on that. You'd say, this is where we catch Pam in her lie. So I would creep up to her and find that moment and don't let her out. You know what I mean? And it inspires so much more creativity. It's so much more respectful. And you're more likely to get what you're looking for. And, you know, I've extended that to direct to everyone, like their actors. You don't tell the costume department, I want him in a suit.
摄像机说，在这句台词时向左摇晃并在那个地方推镜头。你会说，这是我们抓到帕姆说谎的地方。所以我会悄悄靠近她，找到那个时刻，不要放过她。你知道我的意思吗？这能激发更多的创造力。这要尊重得多。而且你更有可能得到你想要的东西。而且，你知道，我把这一点推广到了对待每个人都像对待演员一样。你不会对服装部门说，我想要他穿西装。
You say, this is a character who's so insecure that he takes himself, he tries to tell the world he's important. I want him in a suit. Every day he'll wear a suit. Now the costume designer is so excited, you know, rather than, oh, she went to Sears and got a suit, then you say, make it look fancier.
你会说，这是一个非常没有安全感、以至于试图向世界证明自己很重要的角色。我想要他穿西装。他每天都要穿西装。现在服装设计师就会非常兴奋，你知道的，而不是，哦，她去了西尔斯百货买了一套西装，然后你说，把它弄得更fancy一点。
No one understands what you're doing. No one's motivated. Whereas actors, that's how you talk to an actor, right? And people know that much more. So direct everyone like they're actors is, I think, the best advice I got on that show. Other advice I got later, the other two great pieces of advice, a friend Lee Whannell who just wrote and directed Invisible Man,
没有人明白你在干什么。没有人有积极性。而演员，这才是你和演员对话的方式，对吧？人们对这一点要了解得多得多。所以像对待演员一样导演每个人，我认为是我在那部剧里得到的最好的建议。我后来得到的其他建议，另外两个极好的建议，我的一个朋友李·沃纳尔，他刚刚编剧并导演了《隐形人》，
which I thought was great and he had been a writer forever. He said that he actually took a panel on directing at the Writers Guild of America. He's like, BJ, I want to as Australian accent. He's like, it's the kind of thing you get junk mail for. Come to this seminar, blah, blah, blah. It was the best thing I've ever been to in my life. It was like John Wells. It was Catherine Bigelow. And they were giving practical advice and cynical advice and inspiring advice. And he was like, it was the best thing I've ever been to and everything I tell you is going to be from that. This advice was the best thing I've ever been to and everything I tell you is gonna be from that. This advice was the best thing you can do as a director
我觉得很棒，而且他当了很久的编剧。他说他其实在美国编剧工会参加了一个关于导演的小组讨论。他说，BJ，我想用澳大利亚口音说。他就像是那种你会收到垃圾邮件的类型。来参加这个研讨会吧，巴拉巴拉巴拉。这是我这辈子去过的最好的地方。就像约翰·韦尔斯。就像凯瑟琳·毕格罗。他们给出了实用的建议、讽刺的建议和鼓舞人心的建议。他说，这是我这辈子去过的最好的地方，我告诉你的一切都将源于此。这个建议是作为导演你能做的最好的事情，
is watch the movie in your head as much as you can. Whenever you're in doubt, just take a walk and watch the whole movie in your head again and again and again. And then when you're in a production meeting and someone says, what does the room look like? You just say what you see and they figure it out. You don't need to know what the lens is and what the lighting scheme is.
就是尽可能多地在脑海中观看这部电影。每当你感到怀疑时，就去散散步，一遍又一遍地在脑海里观看整部电影。然后在制作会议上，有人问，这个房间长什么样？你只要说出你看到的，他们就会想办法实现。你不需要知道镜头是什么，打光方案是什么。
If someone says, you know, what are they wearing or how do you want to shoot this? You know, you can say, oh, I picture close ups or I picture, oh, you're like looking from a distance, you know. It will have the same effect as if you studied everything in school because the point is to know the heart. So watch the movie in your head. The other piece of advice that's so simple, this was I have a friend whose father is Al Ruddy, who produced The Godfather. And I asked him if he had any advice on directing. He said, you only need to know two things to direct, what you want and how to get it.
如果有人问，你知道的，他们穿什么或者你想怎么拍？你知道，你可以说，哦，我脑海里是特写镜头，或者我脑海里是，哦，你就像是在远处看，你知道的。这会产生和你把学校里所有东西都学一遍一样的效果，因为重点是要了解内心。所以在脑海里观看这部电影。另一个非常简单的建议，我有位朋友，他的父亲是阿尔·鲁迪，曾制作过《教父》。我问他有没有关于导演的建议。他说，导演只需要知道两件事：你想要什么以及如何得到它。
And I was like, you know what? I think that's the best advice I've gotten for anything. Because those are two very hard things in a way knowing what you want is even harder. But all of us can approach, okay, if you know what you want and how to get it, you'll accomplish anything. And we do that for all sorts of things. And how to get it includes asking someone for help, or to understand something, or to explain something, or to beg them for a favor, or to grind them down because they're just not getting it and whatever it is or inspiring them or whatever you need to get it.
当时我就想，你知道吗？我觉得这是我听过关于任何事情的最好建议。因为这两件事在某种程度上都很难，知道你想要什么甚至更难。但我们所有人都可以着手解决这个问题，好吧，如果你知道你想要什么以及如何得到它，你就能完成任何事。我们针对各种事情都是这么做的。而“如何得到它”包括向某人寻求帮助，或者去理解某事，或者去解释某事，或者恳求他们帮个忙，或者因为他们就是搞不懂而磨他们，无论是什么，或者激励他们，或者为了得到它你需要做的一切。
So that's what you want and how to get it. And then I told them, I ran into him and I was like, you gave me the best advice ever and I quoted him. And he's like, oh, there's a third part. I forgot to tell you. You gotta know when you got it. I was like, I don't like that one. I'm editing that one out.
所以这就是你想要什么以及如何得到它。然后我告诉他，我偶遇了他，我说你给了我史上最好的建议，我还引用了他的话。结果他说，哦，还有第三部分。我忘告诉你了。你得知道你什么时候得到了它。当时我就想，我可不喜欢这一条。我要把这一条剪掉。
You're not wrong. You're not wrong, but it's not as good a quote. And I said that to him. He's like, no, no, you gotta know when. I think he just worked on a movie with some director it took forever. I was like, Al, no, this is not, this is Godfather part three.
你没有错。你没有错，但它作为引言没那么好。我对他是这么说的。他说，不，不，你得知道什么时候。我想他当时刚和某个导演合作了一部电影，花了超级久的时间。我当时就想，阿尔，不，这不是，这是《教父3》。
This is not as good. So I just quote the first two parts. That's so true, BJ. I know, you know, Angela and I changed our whole lives because we wanted to get something. We wanted to get a quality of life. We wanted to be able to make it to soccer practice. We want to take our kids to school. I didn't know you play soccer.
这个没那么好。所以我只引用前两部分。太对了，BJ。我知道，你知道，安吉拉和我改变了我们的整个人生，因为我们想要得到某种东西。我们想要一种生活质量。我们想要能够赶上足球训练。我们想带孩子们去上学。我不知道你还踢足球。
Seriously. I'm sweeper, BJ. Nothing's getting into the goal. No, we just wanted to make our families first. And yeah, just have agency over our own schedules and our time and pour that into our family as a priority. And we didn't know how to get it. That took a long time.
说真的。我是清道夫，BJ。任何东西都别想进球门。不，我们只是想把家庭放在第一位。是的，只是为了掌控我们自己的日程安排和时间，并把这一点作为优先事项投入到家庭中。而我们不知道该如何实现它。这花了很长时间。
It took a lot of experimenting. Years of kind of griping to each other. Yeah. But then eventually we did it. And here we are interviewing you on our podcast, which is the result of our wanting to get something. And we did know how to do it. No, as you were talking. But it's so much easier to figure out how to do it. Like the worst person to work with, someone who doesn't know what they want. Oh my God, what a nightmare, right?
这经历了很多尝试。花了多年时间彼此抱怨。是的。但最终我们做到了。而我们现在在这里，在我们的播客上采访你，这就是我们想要得到某种东西的结果。而我们确实知道该怎么做。不，正如你刚才所说。但弄清楚该怎么做要容易得多。比如最难合作的人，就是那种不知道自己想要什么的人。哦，天哪，简直是一场噩梦，对吧？
You knew what you wanted, so now you're like, I have no idea how to get this. But, like, you figure that out. But you're right. I've worked with directors who don't know what they want, and it really puts everybody through the wringer, you know? You're changing clothes a million times, and you're doing the role different ways, and everyone, it really runs people
你知道你想要什么，所以现在你会想：我不知道怎么得到这个。但是，你可以把这个弄清楚。不过你说得对。我合作过一些不知道自己想要什么的导演，这真的把所有人都折磨得够呛，你知道吗？你得换一百次衣服，你得用不同的方式演这个角色，每个人，这真的把人折磨得
into the ground, but someone with a very clear vision, then you're on set and you're like, okay, well, how do we do it? How do we make this happen? Like, just give me something that I can hang on to. If your vision is clear, we'll get there. Oh, I have one other very cynical piece of directing advice, and it does not make the top three, but it really worked. And someone said to me, who had worked on The Office, said, here's my advice. Pick one shot that's a special shot. It doesn't have to make sense. It just stands out.
精疲力竭，但如果有一个非常清晰愿景的人，你在片场就会想：好吧，那我们怎么做？我们怎么实现它？只要给我一个我可以抓手的东西就行。如果你的愿景很清晰，我们就能做到。哦，我还有另一个非常讽刺的导演建议，它虽然没进前三，但真的很管用。曾有一个在《办公室》工作过的人对我说：这是我的建议。选一个很特别的镜头。它不需要有什么逻辑意义。它只需要很显眼。
It doesn't quite fit. And the network will tell you, you're a great director. Cause they'll notice it and they'll feel proud. And I did that. I think it was maybe in the web, I said, no, I think it was in this. There's a shot where Creed is like standing by the doorway and waiting to go into the room.
它不太合群。然后电视网就会告诉你，你是个伟大的导演。因为他们会注意到它并感到自豪。我照做了。我想那可能是在网络短剧里，我说，不，我觉得是在这一集里。有一个镜头是克里德站在门口等着进房间。
I don't know which episode it was in, but literally the network is that call me person is like, BJ, you are a great director. And it was that shot. And it was like, it was a stretch that the, I mean, it didn't break the office style, but that is a cynical thing. And definitely when you see, like I've joked, the easiest way to win an Oscar is to be a cinematographer and decide to shoot the movie in glorious black and white.
我不知道那是哪一集，但字面意思是电视网打来电话的那个人说：BJ，你是个伟大的导演。就是那个镜头。这有点勉强，我是说，它没有打破《办公室》的风格，但这是一个讽刺的做法。绝对的，当你看到——就像我开玩笑说的，赢得奥斯卡最简单的方法就是成为一名摄影师，然后决定用灿烂的黑白胶卷来拍摄这部电影。
Like anything that calls attention to yourself as a director is so rewarded. Um, so that is my cynical advice. If you do want to, if you're, if you have the chance to direct something and you want people to think you're good, do something visually unusual, which will flatter the intelligence. Do one odd thing and every critic and every person will say, ooh, you know, you're good.
任何吸引人们注意你是个导演的东西都会受到极大的赞赏。嗯，这就是我的讽刺建议。如果你确实想，如果你有机会导演什么东西，并且想让别人觉得你很优秀，那就做一些视觉上不同寻常的事情，这会迎合人们的智力。做一个奇怪的举动，每一个评论家、每一个人都会说：哦，你知道的，你真棒。
Whereas if you just shoot intuitively, like Harold Ramis, you know, you're good. Whereas if you just shoot intuitively, like Harold Ramis, you know, is a great director. He directed a lot for us, but, you know, his movies are classics, but no one talks about him as a great director because he didn't call attention to himself. Rob Reiner, to me, is the greatest director of our lifetimes.
而如果你只是像哈罗德·雷米斯那样直观地拍摄，你知道的，你很棒。而如果你只是像哈罗德·雷米斯那样直观地拍摄，你知道的，他是一位伟大的导演。他为我们导演了很多作品，但是，你知道，他的电影都是经典，但没有人谈论他是一位伟大的导演，因为他没有刻意引人注目。在我看来，罗伯·莱纳是我们有生之年最伟大的导演。
Because if you look at the movies he directed, they are the classics of their genres. He did Spinal Tap, which is the classic mockumentary, Stand By Me, classic coming of age, Princess Bride, classic family movie, Few Good Men, classic, and I don't just mean classic, I mean the epitome of their genre. Harry Met Sally, epitome of romantic comedy.
因为如果你看看他导演的电影，它们就是各自类型的经典。他拍了《摇滚万岁》，那是经典的伪纪录片；《伴我同行》，经典的成长电影；《公主新娘》，经典的家庭电影；《义海雄风》，经典作品，我指的不仅仅是经典，我指的是它们类型的巅峰。当哈利遇到莎妮，浪漫喜剧的巅峰。
And people don't talk about him, you know, because he just did it so right that he was invisible. If he had had like, you know, like an overhead camera in the ceiling fan, and Harry met Sally, everyone's saying he's such a great director. But you know. BG, that reminds me of a piece of
人们不怎么谈论他，你知道的，因为他拍得太好了，以至于他隐形了。如果他在《当哈利遇到莎妮》里加个类似天花板吊扇上的俯拍镜头，所有人都会说他是个伟大的导演。但你知道的。BJ，这让我想起了一个
acting advice that I got that I use all the time. What? So in any project, if it's a TV show or a movie, my acting coach said, you pick one moment for your character that you decide in this project is your big moment of realization, a confession, something. You pick one. And before you say that line, you pause, move forward,
我一直在使用的表演建议。什么？所以在任何项目中，无论是电视剧还是电影，我的表演老师说过，你要为你的角色挑选一个时刻，你决定在这个项目中这就是你的高光时刻：顿悟、忏悔，诸如此类。你只挑一个。在你说出那句台词之前，你停顿一下，身体向前倾，
and then say it. And it will blow people away. And he said, even in auditioning, if you have just an audition scene, you pick one line in that audition scene where you pause and then you lean in before you say that line and you'll get the part every time. I swear to God, after I got that piece of acting advice, I went on a bunch of auditions. I got callbacks for like 12 auditions in a row when I did that little move in thing. And I still use it. I still use that. That's amazing. Okay. This is so funny to me. Is that in your book?
然后再说出来。这会惊艳所有人。他说，甚至在试镜时，如果你只有一个试镜场景，你挑出其中一句台词，在说那句台词之前停顿一下，然后向前倾身，你每次都能拿到角色。我发誓，在我得到这个表演建议后，我参加了一堆试镜。当我做了那个小小的向前倾身的动作时，我连续拿到了大概 12 个试镜的回电。我到现在还在用它。我依然在使用它。这太惊人了。好吧。这对我来说太搞笑了。那在你的书里吗？
I still use that. That's amazing. Okay, this is so funny to me. Is that in your book? It's not in my book because I didn't want to steal his thunder. Oh, got it. Robert Devonzo, my acting coach, and I put him in the book and I said, call this guy and take his class. He'll give you the best advice.
我依然在使用它。这太惊人了。好吧。这对我来说太搞笑了。那在你的书里吗？它不在我的书里，因为我不想抢他的风头。哦，明白了。罗伯特·德万佐，我的表演老师，我把他写进了书里，我说：给这家伙打电话，去上他的课。他会给你最好的建议。
But I guess now I've put it on my podcast. So sorry, Robert. My acting coach did something similar. She was this very amazing older woman. And she said that she was auditioning for a movie. She was from France. And she had an old crown, like some dental work, that as she was giving her big speech,
不过我想现在我把它发到我的播客上了。对不起了，罗伯特。我的表演老师做过类似的事情。她是一个非常了不起的老太太。她说她当时在为一部电影试镜。她是法国人。她有一个旧的牙冠，类似于某种牙科填充物，当她正在发表长篇大论时，
she felt pop off in her mouth. And so she paused with her tongue to put it back in to cover her tooth back. And the pause was so long, the room became quiet. And then once she got her crown back over her tooth, she finished her line and the casting director said, that was the most powerful audition we have ever seen. She got the heart.
她感觉到它在嘴里脱落了。于是她用舌头停顿了一下把它安回原位，把牙齿遮住。停顿的时间太长了，房间里变得鸦雀无声。然后等她把牙冠重新安回牙齿上后，她念完了台词，选角导演说：那是我们见过最具爆发力的试镜。她抓住了核心。
And so she was like, so sometimes you know, pause. That's my French impression, but, and it does. It's like, it's the one moment that doesn't make sense. And people are like, why doesn't that make sense? That's such a good way to distill the common thread of those two things. Yeah. Yeah.
所以她说，所以有时候你知道，停顿一下。这是我的法国腔模仿，但确实如此。这就好像，这是那个看起来没道理的时刻。而人们会想：为什么那个时刻没道理？这真是浓缩这两者共同点的一个好方法。是的。是的。
Well, okay. We actually wanted to talk to you also about what it was like to shoot those two days in the school. You had a huge big group of kids in a classroom. What was it like directing such a big group like that? I guess an advantage of mine is I love talking to kids and groups of kids. Now, they were probably looking back 18 because the way the guilds work,
好吧。其实我们还想和你聊聊，在学校拍摄那两天的体验是什么样的。你在一个教室里有一大群孩子。导演这么大一群人是什么体验？我想我的一个优势是我喜欢和孩子们以及成群的孩子说话。现在，回过头来看，他们可能已经 18 岁了，因为工会的运作方式，
you can work very different hours because of child labor for a kid over 18, or even over 16, the rules are very different. So you'll generally cast people who just turned 18 and look young or just turned 16 and look young for roles that are supposed to be younger. So those kids were probably slightly over 18. That said, they were still like, you know,
因为针对 18 岁以上的儿童劳动法规定，你可以安排非常不同的工作时间，甚至对于 16 岁以上的人，规则也完全不同。所以为了扮演较年轻的角色，你通常会挑选那些刚好满 18 岁但看起来很年轻，或者刚好满 16 岁但看起来很年轻的人。所以那些孩子可能稍微超过 18 岁了。话虽如此，他们依然像，你知道的，
they kid energy playing kid. I just love talking to kids. You know, when I read my kid's book, the book with no pictures, like a classroom, it's like the happiest I am. So I guess to me being like, all right, everybody, here's what happened. You know, this guy, Michael Scott, Steve over here, he did this. They knew it, they got into it. Again, you talk to everyone like their actors, including the background actors, because it was mostly background actors in the class. Most kids didn't speak.
他们是带着孩子气去扮演孩子。我就是喜欢和孩子们说话。你知道的，当我朗读我的童书《没有图画的书》时，面对一个教室，那是我最快乐的时候。所以我想对我来说就是：“好了，大家，情况是这样的。你知道的，这家伙，迈克尔·斯科特，史蒂夫就在这里，他做了这个。”他们懂的，他们很投入。再说一次，你像对待演员一样对待每个人，包括背景演员，因为班里大部分都是背景演员。大多数孩子都不说话。
Just getting them in the mindset of it was really fun for me. They were real, they had good spirit, they were professionals. Then I think it was Lee and Gene, because the writers are so involved on the office or were so involved. I think it was, it was they who taught the kids like the chant and the dance and they were amazing. I love Steve's speech so much. I love his delivery of his speech. You know from the beginning that he's going to have to tell them he's going to have to give his speech, you know from the beginning that he's going to have to tell them. He's going to have to give this speech. But everything about it is so great. He tries
让他们进入那种状态对我来说真的很有趣。他们很真实，很有精神，他们很专业。然后我想是李和吉恩，因为编剧在《办公室》里参与度极高，或者说过去参与度极高。我想是他们，是他们教孩子们口号和舞蹈，他们太棒了。我太喜欢史蒂夫的演讲了。我太喜欢他对台词的演绎了。你从一开始就知道他不得不告诉他们，他将不得不发表这番演讲，你从一开始就知道他必须这么做。他必须发表这番演讲。但关于这一切的一切都太棒了。他试图
to get them to figure it out so he doesn't have to say it, which is amazing. And then he hands out the batteries. Lithium. Yeah. Not laptops or tuition, but some batteries for their laptops. Some lithium batteries. Yeah. Not laptops or tuition, but some batteries for their laptop. Lithium batteries. Yeah. Was that just Steve knowing Michael Scott so well?
让他们自己想明白，这样他就不用说出来了，这太绝了。然后他分发电池。锂电池。是的。不是笔记本电脑或学费，而是他们笔记本电脑的一些电池。一些锂电池。是的。不是笔记本电脑或学费，而是他们笔记本电脑的电池。锂电池。是的。那只是史蒂夫对迈克尔·斯科特太熟悉了吗？
Yeah. That was just Steve doing them so well. Maybe someone pitched, maybe the exact phrasing of, and what's better than laptops, but laptop battery, or what do you need for laptops? I don't know. But it's a collaboration because you see where Steve's going, so you might pitch him a line.
是的。那只是史蒂夫把他们演得太好了。也许有人提议过，也许“还有什么比笔记本电脑更好，但却是笔记本电脑电池”的精确措辞，或者“笔记本电脑需要什么”？我不知道。但这是一种合作，因为你看到了史蒂夫的方向，所以你可能会向他提议一句台词。
But that was, yeah, that was Steve completely. It also was great acting was in the photo where he's surrounded by the kids, phrased on his desk, even that is good photo acting, his optimistic smile. Yes. Oh my gosh. He directed and he said it was so much easier than acting. Really? I thought, wow, that shows how much he's putting into the acting.
但那是，是的，完全是史蒂夫的功劳。同样出色的表演还在那张照片里，他被孩子们包围着，趴在桌子上，甚至连那也是出色的照片表演，他那乐观的微笑。是的。哦，天哪。他当导演，他说这比演戏容易多了。真的吗？我当时想，哇，这说明他在演戏上倾注了多少心血。
Like always, he was the total leader of this episode. He just had to thread that needle and he did it so well. We do want to talk to you about the movie you have coming out that you directed. Can you share with us about it? It's cool. It's called Vengeance. And I wanted to do it. I saw a poster for a movie called Vengeance at the Cannes Film Festival. And I thought, I want to be in a movie called Vengeance.
和往常一样，他是这一集的绝对领袖。他必须穿针引线，而且他做得太棒了。我们确实想跟你聊聊你即将上映的新电影，由你执导的电影。你能和我们分享一下吗？这很酷。它叫《复仇》。我想拍这部电影。我在戛纳电影节上看到了一部名为《复仇》的电影海报。当时我就想，我想参演一部名叫《复仇》的电影。
And I thought, but in a fun way, I was like, if I were in a movie, if you saw me on a movie poster in a movie called Vengeance, you'd know it was different. It wouldn't be like, whoa, he's a cool action star. You'd be like, that's interesting. What's that tone? And honestly, that's where it came from at first. And then I had this plot idea that I just thought really cool. And yeah, so I took it to Blumhouse
我觉得，但要以一种有趣的方式，我想，如果我参演了一部电影，如果你在一张名为《复仇》的电影海报上看到我，你就会知道这很不同。不会像是什么，“哇，他是个酷炫的动作明星”。你会觉得，“这很有趣。这是什么基调？”老实说，最初的想法就是这么来的。然后我有了这个剧情构思，我觉得真的很酷。是的，所以我把它带给了布伦屋制片公司，
because they had just done Get Out, which I thought was another movie that had been really popular despite having such challenging, interesting ideas. Because they didn't just want to make a thinky thing. I wanted it to be fun and funny and, you know, scary and all those things. So, I mean, it was great to get to direct my first feature that had all of those elements, you know.
因为他们刚做完《逃出绝命镇》，我认为那是另一部电影，尽管有着极具挑战性、有趣的想法，却依然大受欢迎。因为他们不仅仅想拍一部烧脑的东西。我希望它是好玩的、搞笑的，你知道的，还有点吓人以及所有这些元素。所以，我是说，能执导我的第一部包含所有这些元素的故事片，感觉太棒了，你知道的。
Wait, so did you write it and direct it and you're in it? Mm-hmm. Wow! Triple threat, BJ! those elements, you know. Wait, so could you write it and direct it and you're in it? Mm-hmm. Wow. Triple threat, BJ. Oh, come on. Three very unthreatening professions, I will say as a caveat. No one's scared of someone who does those three things.
等等，所以你是编剧、导演还在里面演出了？嗯——哼。哇！三栖才子，BJ！这些元素，你知道的。等等，所以你可以编剧、导演并且在里面演出了？嗯——哼。哇。三栖才子，BJ。哦，得了吧。这三个职业都毫无威胁性，作为前提我得这么说。没有人会害怕从事这三项工作的人。
BJ, when does your movie come out? July 29th. Vengeance, out. BJ, thank you so much for coming on Office Ladies. We love you. I love it. on Office Ladies. We love you. I love it. I love it. I love you both.
BJ，你的电影什么时候上映？7 月 29 日。《复仇》，上映。BJ，非常感谢你来到“办公室女士”。我们爱你。我爱。来到“办公室女士”。我们爱你。我爱。我爱。我也爱你们两个。
I don't see you enough. I love talking to you. I love remembering it from this lens with the two of you. It's great. Thank you. You've always been one of my favorite people from the time I met you working on this show. So I love you. Well, that is what a wonderful thing to say,
我见你们的次数不够多。我喜欢和你们聊天。我喜欢从这个角度同你们两个一起回忆过去。这太棒了。谢谢。从我在这部剧里认识你开始，你一直是我最喜欢的人之一。所以我爱你。嗯，这是一件多么美妙的事情，
and I feel exactly the same way. Same. Immediate bonds. I was going to say, I notice Angela's silence here. I would say I feel very similarly about Angela, but if it's not requited, Oh, BJ, I love you so much.
我的感受完全一样。一样。瞬间建立的羁绊。我正想说，我注意到了安吉拉这里的沉默。我想说我对安吉拉也有着非常相似的感受，但如果这不是双向奔赴的话，哦，BJ，我太爱你了。
then what are you going to do? I love you so much. But no, I felt that about both of you from the pilot, really. Okay, see you soon. Family for life. Family for life, BJ. Love you so much. Bye.
那你要怎么办呢？我太爱你了。不过说真的，从试播集开始，我对你们俩就有这种感觉了。好吧，回见。一生挚友。一生挚友，BJ。非常爱你们。再见。
Well, that was so fun, Angela. I love talking to BJ. I love that we got into that cool discussion about directing. I felt like it's when we had Mike Schur on and we were talking all about the writing process. I know. I could listen to BJ talk all day. Truly. He's so smart. I love him so much. I love his brain. I told him that. I said, BJ, I love your brain. Is that a weird thing to say to someone? No, I love his brain as well. It's so good to be back in the studio. Hi, Cassie.
哇，那太有趣了，安吉拉。我喜欢和 BJ 聊天。我喜欢我们深入探讨导演的那段对话。我觉得这就好像我们邀请迈克·舒尔来做客，然后我们大谈编剧过程的时候一样。我知道。我可以听 BJ 说上一整天。真的。他太聪明了。我太喜欢他了。我爱他的大脑。我当时就是这么告诉他的。我说：BJ，我爱你的大脑。对某人说这话会不会很奇怪？不，我也很爱他的大脑。回到录音室真好。嗨，卡茜。
We missed you. Hi, welcome back. Thank you. Yes, I guess what we haven't shared with everyone was that we actually took a two-week break from the podcast. We made sure to double record episodes so that you didn't miss us, but we were off recording the audiobook for the Office BFFs. Oh my gosh. You guys, I mean,
我们想念你。嗨，欢迎回来。谢谢。是的，我想我们还没和大家分享的是，我们其实从播客中请了两周假。我们确保双倍录制了剧集，这样你们就不会想念我们，但我们是去录制《办公室死党》的有声书了。哦，天哪。你们知道吗，
I listen to audiobooks. I have a newfound respect for how they come together. We sat in a room together and read all day. It was a teeny tiny little like padded room, truly. And we read our book. One day at lunch, I had hummus. Oh, yeah. And after lunch, my stomach kept making all these noises because I had a spousy hummus. It was so embarrassing. We had to stop the audiobook and our amazing director, Dennis, had to go get a pillow and cover my stomach with a pillow. And he said, don't worry, Angela, it happens all the time. Yeah.
我听有声书。我对它们是如何制作出来的有了全新的敬意。我们一起坐在一个房间里读了一整天。那是一个超级微型、加了隔音垫的小房间，真的。我们在读我们的书。有一天午餐时，我吃了鹰嘴豆泥。哦，对。午餐后，我的肚子一直在发出各种声音，因为我吃了胀气的鹰嘴豆泥。太尴尬了。我们不得不暂停有声书录制，我们出色的导演丹尼斯不得不去拿了一个枕头，用枕头挡住我的肚子。他说：别担心，安吉拉，这经常发生。对。
And then the next day it happened to me. So the next day we're recording our audiobook. We both have pillows on our stomachs. Oh my gosh, it was so embarrassing, but so much fun. You guys, I can't wait for you to hear the audio book. We put our heart and soul into it and so many office cast mates make these great appearances in the audio book.
然后第二天轮到我了。所以第二天我们在录有声书。我们俩肚子上都放着枕头。哦，天哪，太尴尬了，但也超级有趣。伙计们，我等不及让你们听这本书的有声书了。我们倾注了全部心血，而且有那么多的办公室演员都在有声书中惊喜客串。
I'm really proud of it. I can't wait for you guys to hear it. Yeah, we really wanted to make it something separate from the book. In the book, you're gonna get to see all of our personal photos. So we thought, well, how could we put some special audio surprises in the audiobook
我真的为它感到骄傲。我迫不及待想让你们听听了。是的，我们真的很想把它做得独立于书本身。在书里，你们会看到我们所有的个人照片。所以我们想，嗯，我们怎么能在有声书中加入一些特别的音频惊喜呢？
so we can't wait for you to hear it? Yeah, our friends and castmates really came through. Well, it's available for pre-order now wherever you listen to audiobooks. And I think we should start breaking down this episode. Let's do it. Let's do it. This episode begins with a hilarious cold open. It's Andy and Michael in Michael's office. And guess what? Andy's baby talk is back.
所以我们迫不及待想让你们听听了！是的，我们的朋友和演员搭档们真的很给力。好了，现在无论你在哪里听有声书，都可以开始预订了。我想我们应该开始剖析这一集了。我们开始吧。开始吧。这一集以一个爆笑的开场白开始。安迪和迈克尔在迈克尔的办公室里。你猜怎么着？安迪的婴儿语又回来了。
I loved it. I love that Michael makes Andy read his baby talk off a card? Oh, Jenna, I got so tickled in this scene. I literally like was giggling when Michael then reads Andy's baby talk back to Andy. I mean, you have to hear it. You have to hear it. You are also on record as saying, widow ittle, footy woodies, num nums, jammies, make boom boom, with dick-a-awas and woad eyewind.
我太喜欢了。我喜欢迈克尔让安迪照着卡片念他的婴儿语？哦，珍娜，我在这个场景里笑死我了。当迈克尔把安迪的婴儿语回读给安迪听时，我简直像在咯咯傻笑。我是说，你得听听。你必须听听。你还有案可查地说过：“widow ittle, footy woodies, num nums, jammies, make boom boom, with dick-a-awas and woad eyewind。”
Do I sometimes replace r's with w's? Do I sometimes repeat a word to get my point across? Well if I do, Andy, sorry. You can't be a baby in the office. It makes me look like I hire babies. When he says it makes me look like I higher baby, he says it so seriously. You know, Angela, my cat, Andi, he used to say, ridiculous. When things bothered him, he would say, oh my God, that is ridiculous.
我有时会把 r 发成 w 的音吗？我有时会重复一个词来表达我的观点吗？好吧，如果我这么做了，安迪，对不起。你不能在办公室里当个婴儿。这让我看起来像是在雇佣婴儿。当他说这让他看起来像是在“higher baby”（雇佣婴儿）时，他说得太严肃了。你知道的，安吉拉，我的猫安迪，他以前常说“荒谬”。当事情困扰他时，他会说：“哦，天哪，这太荒谬了。”
It's so, so ridiculous, mama. You mean when you did your voice of your cat, Jenna? I channeled what he was actually saying, Angela. Jenna has voices for all of her pets. Yep, Sunny has one, Maggie has one. Yep. Oh, what's Maggie's? Maggie's?
太荒谬了，妈妈。你是说当你模仿你的猫的声音时，珍娜？我是在传达它实际在表达的意思，安吉拉。珍娜为她所有的宠物都配了音。对，桑尼有一个，玛吉有一个。对。哦，玛吉的是什么样的？玛吉的？
I know Sunny's. Maggie's is like this. Hey guys, hey, did you want this shoe? Do you want it? You can have it. Hey, oh, what's that? Oh, look, that you want this shoe? Do you want it? You can have it, hey. Oh, what's that? Oh, look, that orange fella's back again.
我知道桑尼的。玛吉的是这样的。嘿，伙计们，嘿，你们想要这只鞋吗？你们想要吗？你们可以拿去。嘿，哦，那是什么？哦，看，那个橘色的小家伙又回来了。
Yeah. Maggie's just so optimistic about everything. She's joyous. Maggie's joyous. Although every single morning in our house, it is like Groundhog Day. It is like Maggie is meeting Sunny for the first time. Every morning she reacts like, oh my God, there's a cat in the kitchen. It is like Maggie is meeting Sonny for the first time.
对。玛吉对任何事都超级乐观。她很欢乐。玛吉很欢乐。虽然我们家里的每一个早晨，都像是《土拨鼠之日》。就像玛吉是第一次见到桑尼一样。每天早晨她的反应都是：“哦，天哪，厨房里有一只猫。”就像玛吉是第一次见到桑尼一样。
Every morning she reacts like, oh my God, there's a cat in the kitchen. I must follow it, I must get it, what is it? And they do this whole routine and then about 45 minutes later, everybody's fine again. But every morning. Every morning she is seeing the cat for the very first time in her life. Oh my gosh.
每天早晨她的反应都是：“哦，天哪，厨房里有一只猫。”我必须跟着它，我必须抓住它，那是什么？然后他们进行完这一整套流程，大约 45 分钟后，大家又都恢复正常了。但每天早晨。每天早晨她都是生命中第一次见到这只猫。哦，天哪。
It's crazy. It's crazy. Oh my gosh. It's crazy. That's crazy. Well, that's ridiculous. This scene ends with Andy complimenting Michael's Elvis impression. He said other people don't like it, but I like it. And Michael says, this made me laugh so hard. Michael goes, you're welcome, baby. I know.
太疯狂了。太疯狂了。哦，天哪。太疯狂了。这太疯狂了。好吧，这也太荒谬了。这个场景以安迪赞美迈克尔的猫王模仿秀结束。他说其他人不喜欢，但他喜欢。迈克尔说，这把我逗得哈哈大笑。迈克尔说，不客气，宝贝。我知道。
It's too good. Well, the main plot of this episode is going to get started when Andy bursts into Jim's office. Yeah, Dr. TunaMD. We have terrible news. We have a serious case of the bundes. And there's one cure. We need an employee of the month contest. Background catch in this scene. Tell me. One minute, 54 seconds.
太棒了。好吧，这一集的主线剧情将从安迪闯入吉姆的办公室开始。是的，金枪鱼医学博士。我们有个可怕的消息。我们得了严重的“蹦迪病”（bundes）。只有一个解药。我们需要一个“月度员工”评比。这个场景里有个背景彩蛋。告诉我。1分54秒。
Hang with me here over Andy's shoulder through Jim's clear glass panel. What do you see at front reception? The golf picture still on the wall. That's right. This is seven weeks. This has been going on. Where's Pam's painting? Right after this as an Andy talking head, I had to bring it up, you guys, because he mentions he spent a summer at Enron.
跟我一起来，透过吉姆的透明玻璃隔板看安迪的肩膀。你在前台看到了什么？墙上还挂着高尔夫球的照片。没错。这已经是七周了。这件事一直在持续。彭的画去哪了？紧接着这是一个安迪的单人访谈，我不得不提一下，各位，因为他提到他在安然（Enron）度过了一个夏天。
What all is Andy doing in his summers? So add it to the list. We have that he spent a summer at Enron, a summer in Toulouse apprenticing to be a Fomagier, and he spent every summer at a dialect camp from age 7 to 18 and then went on to be a counselor for 10 years. What is happening with Andy Summers? How long are his Summers? Very long. They're very crowded with things. I love this next scene so much, Angela. Aaron is helping Michael attempt to clean out his inbox.
安迪在夏天都做些什么？所以把它加到清单里。我们知道他在安然度过了一个夏天，在图卢兹度过了一个夏天，当学徒想成为一名奶酪专家（Fomagier），从7岁到18岁，他每个夏天都去方言夏令营，然后当了10年辅导员。安迪的夏天到底怎么回事？他的夏天有多长？非常长。里面塞满了各种事情。我太喜欢接下来的这个场景了，安吉拉。艾琳正在帮迈克尔清理收件箱。
It hit a little too close to home for me personally. Did it? One of my favorite things that Erin says, she says he has a news alert for nip slip. And he says, oh my gosh, that must be hackers. So there was another line in the script before Jim comes in to interrupt. Erin had a line where she said, you also have a news
对我个人来说，这有点太真实了。是吗？艾琳说的话里我最喜欢的一句是，她说他有一条关于“走光”（nip slip）的新闻提醒。他说，哦，天哪，那一定是被黑客攻击了。所以在吉姆进来打断之前，剧本里还有另一句台词。艾琳有一句台词是，你还有一条关于
alert for nipple slip. And I thought that was so funny. I wish it had stayed in. But instead, we needed to get Jim in there. Well, Michael has 836 messages in his inbox. And I just want to point out that my email is in worse shape than Michael's. Oh, no, lady.
“乳头走光”（nipple slip）的新闻提醒。我觉得太搞笑了。我真希望它能保留下来。但相反，我们需要让吉姆进来。好吧，迈克尔的收件箱里有836条未读消息。我只想指出，我的邮箱状况比迈克尔的还要糟糕。哦，不，女士。
You told me last night you cleared a bunch of stuff. I did, but it's just still so large. That's what she said. You need to organize it by unread, and then go through and just click on all the ads and stuff that you never get rid of. I'm trying. See what it says now?
你昨晚告诉我你清理了很多东西。我是清理了，但它还是太大了。她就是这么说的。你需要按未读排序，然后浏览一下，点击那些你永远不会摆脱的广告之类的东西。我在试。看看现在上面写的是什么？
1,589. Yeah. My inbox is worse than Michael's. What is yours, Jenna? Like seven? Eight. Oh, I was so close. Eight unread.
1,589。是的。我的收件箱比迈克尔的还糟。你的呢，珍娜？大概七个？八个。哦，我太接近了。八个未读。
And I think one of those is still one of those, do you get those from Baby Center where they're still telling you about your kids and milestones? Remember when you first signed up for them, you were pregnant and then they were like a lima bean and then they were like a- Yeah, like an orange and then- Yeah. What I get is today in your memories from Shutterfly and then I click on it and it brings me to tears all the time because it's my daughter being adorable.
我想其中一个仍然是那种，你从Baby Center收到的那种，它们还在向你讲述关于你孩子的成长里程碑吗？还记得你第一次注册的时候吗，你怀孕了，然后它们就像一颗利马豆，然后它们就像一个——是的，就像一个橙子，然后——是的。我收到的是来自Shutterfly的“回顾当年的今天”，然后我点击它，总是让我泪流满面，因为那是我的女儿，太可爱了。
Well, maybe you want to keep those, but the other ones, you got to click unsubscribe. You got to stop the flow. I got to stop the flow. I'll help you one day. OK. Well, listen, Jim is going to come in, and he's going to pitch this employee of the month idea. And Michael's like, sure, go for it.
好吧，也许你想留着那些，但其他的，你得点击取消订阅。你得阻止这种洪流。我得阻止这种洪流。我改天帮你。好的。好吧，听着，吉姆要进来了，他要提出这个月度员工的点子。迈克尔说，当然，放手去吧。
But now we're going to find out what's really going on. Because Andy is going to tell Dwight that Jim totally went for their idea of employee of the month. And Dwight's like, no, no, no, that was your idea, your idea. Dwight's up to something. What he's up to is that in six hours, Jim will be fired by David Wallace. I'm interested to see how that goes down. Well, in the break room, Pam is eating yogurt
但现在我们要弄清楚到底是怎么回事。因为安迪要告诉德怀特，吉姆完全赞同他们关于月度员工的点子。德怀特却说，不，不，不，那是你的点子，你的点子。德怀特在搞什么鬼。他要搞的是，六小时后，吉姆就会被大卫·华莱士解雇。我很想看看事情会怎么发展。好吧，在茶水间里，彭正在吃酸奶，
when Erin enters to ask her to look over an itinerary. That's right. We had a fan catch from Kelsey in Kentucky who said, when Phyllis, Pam, and Erin are in the break room looking at the itinerary, it's very obvious, again, how much purple is in the wardrobe design. Oh, I noticed. And later in the bullpen, you'll notice Angela Martin also has a purple lilac
这时艾琳走进来请她帮忙过目一份行程表。没错。我们收到了来自肯塔基州的凯尔西的粉丝彩蛋，她说，当菲利斯、彭和艾琳在茶水间看行程表时，再次非常明显地看出服装设计里有多少紫色。哦，我注意到了。后来的办公区里，你也会注意到安吉拉·马丁也穿了一件紫丁香色的
cardigan. It was a purple day. You and Kelsey are sharing a brain today. We are. Well, this itinerary has one very interesting line item. Pam is surprised to learn that the Michael Scott Foundation is still in existence. And Phyllis says, what's Scott's Tots? And Stanley starts laughing and says, has it really been 10 years? I mean, Stanley isn't just laughing.
开衫。今天是紫色日。你和凯尔西今天共用一个大脑。我们是的。好吧，这份行程表上有一个非常有趣的条目。彭惊讶地发现迈克尔·斯科特基金会居然还在。菲利斯说，“斯科特 Tots”是什么？斯坦利开始大笑并说，真的已经10年了吗？我的意思是，斯坦利可不仅仅是在笑。
It is a laugh that comes like from a deep place of like, oh, this guy is screwed. And I am thrilled to watch it happen. Well Stanley's going to hold up a newspaper. The headline reads, local businessman pledges college tuition to third graders. We kind of talked about this with BJ a little bit. And we got a fan mail flurry about this newspaper article that Stanley's holding up.
这笑声来自一个内心深处，仿佛在说，这家伙完蛋了。我很高兴看到这一幕发生。好吧，斯坦利要举起一份报纸。头条写着：当地商人承诺资助三年级学生大学学费。我们之前跟B.J.稍微聊过这个。我们收到了大量关于斯坦利举着的这篇报纸文章的粉丝来信。
Because it looks like the real Scranton Times. It really does. This is fakey fil shay, but it's done amazingly. It is actually a real Scranton Times newspaper. Randy Cordray explained how we made this amazing prop. So first, they hired a group of kids to take a picture with Michael Scott at school, and Kim Ferry even styled Steve's hair in a retro Caesar style hairdo. You know that one that was made popular by George Clooney in the early years of ER?
因为它看起来就像真的《斯克兰顿时报》。真的很像。这是假冒伪劣，但做得太棒了。它实际上是一份真实的《斯克兰顿时报》。兰迪·科德雷（Randy Cordray）解释了我们是如何制作这个惊人的道具的。首先，他们雇了一群孩子在学校和迈克尔·斯科特合影，金·费里（Kim Ferry）甚至把史蒂夫的头发设计成复古恺撒发型。你知道那种由乔治·克鲁尼在《急诊室的故事》早期带火的发型吗？
Oh, yes. Yes. I mean, that's how detailed they were about this photo. They think Michael Scott would be into this hairdo. So then Phil Shea contacted the Scranton Times and asked for a copy of their newspaper from 10 years ago. And when he was looking through it, he said, do you think you would be willing to reproduce the local page?
哦，是的。是的。我的意思是，他们对这张照片的细节要求就是这么高。他们认为迈克尔·斯科特会喜欢这种发型。于是菲尔·谢伊联系了《斯克兰顿时报》，索要他们10年前的报纸副本。当他浏览时，他说，你们愿意重新制作本地版吗？
So not the front page, but the local page with a different feature story at the bottom of the page so that we can use it on our show. Wow. So the writers wrote a fake article and Randy Schemansky, who worked at the Times, put it all together. He put his name as the writer in the byline and printed it for us. Nice, Randy. Thank you. Well, that's why it looks so real. Yeah. Well, there's photos of it online and there's also some on Office Tally and I'll put some of those in our stories. Yes, the entire text of the article is on OfficeTally.com, and I thought I would read
不是头版，而是本地版，在页面底部放一个不同的专题报道，以便我们能在节目中使用它。哇。于是编剧们写了一篇假文章，曾在《时报》工作的兰迪·谢曼斯基（Randy Schemansky）把这一切拼凑在了一起。他把自己的名字写在署名处，并为我们打印了出来。干得好，兰迪。谢谢。好吧，这就是为什么它看起来那么真实。是的。网上有它的照片，Office Tally上也有一些，我会把其中一些放到我们的动态里。是的，整篇文章都可以在OfficeTally.com上找到，我想我应该读一下
one of my favorite passages. The whole thing is worth a read, but this one really goes with the episode. It says, Taleb Johnson, a student in Alice Kay's class, has dreams of becoming a doctor. Taleb's mother has already been trying to save for the daunting $120,000 cost of medical school, and she was not sure if it could ever be a reality. But now that Scott has offered to pick up the tab, Mrs. Johnson said that Tlaib would undoubtedly be going to an Ivy League university. That's in the article. It's very on theme. I know. Well, Jenna, I have a little section I'm That's in the article. It's very on theme.
我最喜欢的段落之一。整篇文章都值得一读，但这篇真的和这一集很搭。上面写着：“阿里斯·凯（Alice Kay）班上的学生塔莱布·约翰逊（Taleb Johnson）有着当医生的梦想。塔莱布的母亲一直在努力为医学院高达12万美元的高昂费用存钱，她不确定这是否会成为现实。但现在斯科特已经主动承担了这笔费用，约翰逊太太说塔莱布毫无疑问将进入常春藤盟校。”这就在文章里。非常契合主题。我知道。好吧，珍娜，我有一个小板块，我称之为
I know. Well, Jenna, I have a little section I'm calling According to the Internet. Oh. Yeah. When you type in Scott's Tots, lots of stuff comes up. I'm going to share three with you. The first one is, according to the Internet, you might ask yourself, how much money would Michael have to pay for all of their tuition? Oh. Assuming all 15 of Scott's Tots attended a four-year private university, Michael would
“根据互联网”。哦。是的。当你输入“斯科特 Tots”时，会出现很多东西。我要和你们分享三个。第一个是，根据互联网，你可能会问自己，迈克尔得为他们所有人支付多少学费？哦。假设所有15个“斯科特 Tots”都上了四年制私立大学，迈克尔可能
probably have to pay something around $1.9 million. Wow. Yeah. So, when he made this promise 10 years ago, he believed he would have so much money that he'd have like an extra two million. That's right. Number two, if you go to Oklahoma State University in Stillwater, Oklahoma, you can join a student club called Scott's Tots.
不得不支付大约190万美元。哇。是的。所以，当他在10年前做出这个承诺时，他相信自己会有那么多钱，以至于他会多出大约两百万。没错。第二，如果你去俄克拉荷马州的斯蒂勒沃特市的俄克拉荷马州立大学，你可以加入一个名为“斯科特 Tots”的学生俱乐部。
What does Scott's Tots do? According to the online newspaper of the school, the O'Callie, staff reporter Jake Sellers wrote, members of the Scott's Tots Club meet weekly to stream and test their knowledge on NBC's The Office. This semester, the club started fresh, mostly meeting in classroom building on Wednesdays. And it goes on to say, although this club may be a time
“斯科特 Tots”做什么？根据该校的网络报纸《O'Callie》，特约记者杰克·塞勒斯（Jake Sellers）写道，“斯科特 Tots”俱乐部的成员每周聚会，观看并测试他们对NBC情景喜剧《办公室》的知识了解。这学期，俱乐部重新开始，主要在周三于教学楼聚会。
for some students to watch a show, for some it is a time to connect. Haley McCauley, senior business manager, is the secretary of Scott's Tots. McCauley, senior business manager, is the secretary of Scott's Tots. McCauley joined in the fall of her freshman year, and she says they have trivia nights with prizes for the winners, and quote, she says, it's a really fun club. The article also included a flyer they had made for their club. I'm going to put it in our stories. Oh, I love it. It's got a gym face on it and a dundee. Yeah, and the stapler and the jello. It says it has their campus link. And this
文章接着说，虽然这个俱乐部对某些学生来说可能是看剧的时间，但对一些人来说，它是建立联系的时间。高级业务经理海莉·麦考利（Haley McCauley）是“斯科特 Tots”的秘书。麦考利（高级业务经理，是“斯科特 Tots”的秘书——译者注：原文重复）。麦考利在大一的秋天加入了俱乐部，她说他们有知识问答之夜，为赢家准备了奖品，并且引用原话，她说，“这真的是一个很有趣的俱乐部。”文章还附上了他们为俱乐部制作的传单。我要把它发到我们的动态里。哦，我太喜欢了。上面有吉姆的脸和一个邓迪奖。是的，还有订书机和果冻。上面说有他们的校园链接。这就是上面写的内容。
is what it says. We watch the office show and have trivia nights once a month. We have snacks exclamation point. Well, you and I are going. I know. And then it says where you can join to be a member. And according to the internet number three, I found a ton, like too many to list, youth soccer teams named Scotts Tots all across the United States. Wow. Mm-hmm. You can go cheer on Scotts Tots at almost any soccer field on a Saturday in America. So that's some stuff I found on the internet, but we should go back to the break room because Pam has a very different reaction than Stanley
我们观看《办公室》这部剧，并且每月举行一次知识问答之夜。我们有零食（感叹号）。好吧，你和我都要去。我知道。然后上面写着你在哪里可以加入成为会员。根据互联网第三点，我发现了超级多，多得数不清的、全美各地名叫“斯科特 Tots”的青年足球队。哇。嗯哼。你可以在美国周六的几乎任何一个足球场上为“斯科特 Tots”加油呐喊。所以这些是我在网上找到的一些东西，但我们应该回到茶水间，因为彭对这个信息的反应与斯坦利截然不同。
to this information. I mean, Pam uses the word terrible like five times. She feels like she's not getting through to Michael. She's like, why would you promise something like that? This is a terrible thing, Michael. This is terrible. It's just terrible. And she's like, you have to go tell them now.
我是说，彭用了大约五次“可怕”这个词。她觉得她没能跟迈克尔沟通。她说，你怎么能承诺那种事？这是一件可怕的事，迈克尔。这太可怕了。简直太可怕了。她说，你现在必须去告诉他们。
Did you see the article, Angela, where it sort of broke down, there are two reactions to this episode from viewers. You're either a Stanley or a Pam. Like it was saying, you're either a person who laughs through tragedy. You know, you're that person at the funeral who gets the giggles. Right. Right. Or you have no sense of humor about it. They were sort of saying like, if you're a Pam, you probably can't watch this episode. Right. It's a really interesting article, actually. It's on decider.com. And I don't know which one I am. I mean, I have a visceral reaction at like, I feel so bad for these kids.
安吉拉，你看到那篇文章了吗？它大致分析了观众对这一集的两种反应。你要么是斯坦利，要么是彭。就像它说的，你要么是一个在悲剧中笑出声的人。你知道的，你就是葬礼上那个忍不住咯咯笑的人。对。对。或者你对此毫无幽默感。他们有点像是在说，如果你是彭，你可能根本看不了这一集。对。其实这是一篇非常有趣的文章。它在decider.com上。我也不知道我是哪一种。我是说，我有一种发自内心的反应，比如，我太为这些孩子感到难过了。
And I also see Stanley finally getting to see Michael get his comeuppance. Yes. I don't know which one I am either. I enjoyed this episode. So I guess I must be a little Stanley. Maybe we're a combo. I don't know who that would be.
而且我也看到斯坦利终于看到迈克尔得到应有的报应了。是的。我也不知道我是哪一种。我很喜欢这一集。所以我猜我一定有点像斯坦利。也许我们是结合体。我都不知道那会是谁。
Are you an Erin then? Erin seems horrified and yet also, she still finds a positive spin at the end. Yeah, maybe we're Aaron. The article said about people who are Stanleys, and I thought this was worded really well, they're not heartless. They're almost shocked to the point of hilarity. Right. When something is so insanely absurd to you that someone could do that, that you're like, what? That's their coping mechanism. Yeah. Right. When something is so insanely absurd to you that someone could do that, that you're like, what?
那你是个艾琳吗？艾琳看起来吓坏了，但同时，她在最后还是找到了一个积极的转折点。是的，也许我们是艾琳。文章谈到那些像斯坦利的人时，我觉得这段话表达得很好，他们不是铁石心肠。他们震惊得甚至觉得荒诞好笑了。对。当某件事对你来说是如此疯狂地荒谬，竟然有人能做出那种事，以至于你会想，什么？那是他们的应对机制。是的。对。
That's their coping mechanism. Yeah. Right. Whereas Pam, it's just all just torturous. Yeah. Well, I was really disappointed because I didn't get to go with Michael. As an actor, I wanted to see Pam take Michael
而对彭来说，这一切简直就是折磨。是的。好吧，我真的很失望，因为我没能跟迈克尔一起去。作为一个演员，我想看到彭带着迈克尔
to this moment in his life, but Pam refuses to go. Right. Aaron's going to have to do it, but I was very jealous as an actor. That you didn't get to go spend the day with Steve and watch him do these amazing scenes. Yes. Well, Michael now has this famous talking head. We talked about it a little bit with BJ where he says, I just, you know, I fell in love with those kids. And so he made him a promise. He wanted to help them. He wanted to see them graduate from high school and
经历他生命中的这个时刻，但彭拒绝去。没错，艾琳不得不去，但作为一个演员我真的很嫉妒。嫉妒你没能去和史蒂夫一起度过一天，看他演这些精彩的场景。是的。好吧，迈克尔现在有了一个著名的单人访谈。我们之前跟B.J.稍微聊过这个，他说，我只是，你知道的，我爱上了那些孩子们。所以他向他们许下承诺。他想帮助他们。他想看他们从高中毕业，
he would pay for their college. Yes. This is sort of the explanation behind this predicament, behind the premise for this episode. We got a fan question from Erin in Oxford, Ohio who said this, I recently watched The Big Lebowski and there is a specific scene that caught my eye. In the scene, the dude is visiting Mr. Lebowski's house. During the visit, he's given a tour of the study and notices a picture on the wall of Mr. Lebowski surrounded by a bunch of smiling high school age children. The dude asks, Oh, are those Mr. Lebowski's children?
并且他会为他们的大学买单。是的。这可以说是造成这种困境、这一集故事前提背后的解释。我们收到了一位来自俄亥俄州牛津市的艾琳的粉丝提问，她是这样说的：我最近观看了《谋杀绿脚趾》（The Big Lebowski），有一个特定的场景吸引了我的眼球。在那个场景中，“老dude”正在拜访勒博斯基先生的家。在拜访期间，他参观了书房，并注意到墙上挂着一张照片，照片上勒博斯基先生被一群面带微笑的高中年龄的孩子们包围着。“老dude”问，哦，这些是勒博斯基先生的孩子吗？
To which the butler replies, They're not literally his children. They're the Little Lebowski Urban Achievers, inner-city children of promise but without the necessary means for a higher education, so Mr. Lebowski has committed to sending all of them to college. My question is, did the writers have it in their head that Michael saw this movie and that this might have led him to making a similar promise, or is it just a coincidence? I had to find out. So I reached out to Gene and Lee, who wrote this episode, and they said that the idea for this episode
管家回答说：他们严格意义上不是他的孩子。他们是“小勒博斯基城市成就者”（Little Lebowski Urban Achievers），那些有前途的内城儿童，但缺乏接受高等教育的必要经济条件，所以勒博斯基先生承诺送他们所有人去上大学。我的问题是，编剧们是否在脑子里想着迈克尔看过这部电影，这可能导致他做出了类似的承诺，还是这纯属巧合？我必须弄清楚。所以我联系了写这一集的吉恩（Gene）和李（Lee），他们说这一集的创意
actually came from Paul Lieberstein. Paul confirmed this, and when I asked him if the idea was inspired by the Big Lebowski, he said no, that he wasn't even aware of that scene in the movie. Paul said that there was a real story of a businessman who did this with extraordinary success back in the 1990s. He thinks maybe it was Chicago. He couldn't quite remember.
其实来自保罗·利伯斯坦（Paul Lieberstein）。保罗证实了这一点，当我问他这个创意是否受到《谋杀绿脚趾》的启发时，他说没有，他甚至不知道电影里有那个场景。保罗说，在20世纪90年代，确实有一个真实的故事，一个商人取得了非凡的成功。他觉得可能是芝加哥。他记不太清了。
But it was a high school where the graduation rate was incredibly low. But within the group of kids that he made this promise to, all of them went to college. And Paul just remembered the photo in the newspaper, and he said that seems like something Michael Scott would do. That Michael, because of his good heart and being so sure that he would be a millionaire by the time these kids graduated, that he would want to help and he would make this promise. He said, quote, it felt like a really honest problem coming from this character. So that was the inspiration was this article that he had seen of someone doing this successfully and thinking Michael Scott wouldn't do it successfully though.
但那是一所高中，毕业率低得惊人。但在他做出这个承诺的那群孩子中，所有人最后都上了大学。保罗只是记起了报纸上的照片，他说这看起来像迈克尔·斯科特会做的事。迈克尔因为心地善良，又极其确信这些孩子毕业时他就会成为百万富翁，所以他会想去帮忙并许下这个承诺。他说，原话是，“感觉这是一个来自这个角色的非常真实的困境。”所以灵感就是他看到过的一篇关于某人成功做到这一点的文章，并认为迈克尔·斯科特不会成功做到这一点。
He'd want to do it, but he wouldn't be able to follow through. Yeah, so he said the idea was his, but Lee and Jean made it their own. They came up with the dance, the batteries. He said that was all them. But that was the inspiration behind Scott's Tots. Well, I love that. I always love finding out the inspiration for our episodes. Mm-hmm. It's usually some little thing that just stuck with someone. Yeah.
他会想做，但他无法坚持到底。是的，所以他说创意是他的，但李和吉恩加入了他们自己的特色。他们想出了舞蹈、电池。他说那些全都是他们的点子。但这背后的灵感就是“斯科特 Tots”。好吧，我喜欢这样。我总是很喜欢去了解我们剧集的灵感来源。嗯哼。通常只是一些黏在某人脑海里的小事情。是的。
Meanwhile, in the kitchen, Dwight is continuing to act strange. Yeah, he's showering Jim with compliments, and then he provides him with a spreadsheet so that Jim can rank everyone based on performance for his employee of the month project. He says he'll run it over to Toby in the accounting department.
与此同时，在厨房里，德怀特继续表现得很奇怪。是的，他用赞美淹没吉姆，然后他给吉姆提供了一个电子表格，这样吉姆就可以为了他的月度员工项目，根据表现给每个人排名。他说他会把这个拿给会计部的托比。
So it'll just be like totally impartial. They'll run the data. Exactly. Just data based. Did you notice during the scene what Rain took out of the fridge at the beginning? Like his excuse for going into the kitchen is to get something out of the fridge to run into Jim.
所以这就完全公正了。他们会运行数据。没错。完全基于数据。你注意到在这个场景里，雷恩（Rain）一开始从冰箱里拿出了什么吗？他去厨房的借口是拿冰箱里的东西，好撞上吉姆。
No, what was it? Mustard. What's he doing with mustard? I don't know. Did he do anything with it? He does nothing with the mustard, but when they pull back wide, there are more things on the counter that he has gotten out of the fridge. He also got out jelly and I think barbecue sauce.
不，是什么？芥末。他拿着芥末干嘛？我不知道。他用它做什么了吗？他根本没用芥末，但当镜头拉远时，台面上还有更多他从冰箱里拿出来东西。他还拿了果冻，我想还有烧烤酱。
Gross. So he's definitely, I guess, heavy in the condiments. Is jelly a condiment? Is jelly a condiment? I mean, you put it on, is butter a condiment? I'm going to say no. What is a condiment? Isn't a condiment like, well, I guess isn't it like the extras? So maybe you're right. I mean, what is a condiment? Like salt and pepper? No, that's a spice. Oh, I'm sorry.
太恶心了。所以他绝对，我猜，对调味品情有独钟。果冻是调味品吗？果冻是调味品吗？我是说，你把它涂在——黄油是调味品吗？我得说不是。什么是调味品？调味品难道不是那种，嗯，我猜难道不是像额外添加的东西吗？所以也许你是对的。我是说，什么是调味品？比如盐和胡椒？不，那是香料。哦，对不起。
The definition of condiment is a substance such as salt or ketchup that is used to add flavor to food. Thank you. Spices are condiments? Look who was right about something. I found a chart that lists the calories in different condiments. Did you know honey is considered a condiment?
调味品的定义是一种用于为食物增添风味的物质，如盐或番茄酱。谢谢。香料是调味品？看看是谁对了一回。我找到了一张列出不同调味品卡路里的表。你知道蜂蜜被认为是一种调味品吗？
Well, that makes sense now. They're listing marinara as a condiment. It enhances flavor. Everything enhances flavor. An onion enhances flavor. Everything enhances flavor. An onion enhances flavor. Garlic. Does it have to be... Do you have to squeeze it out of a bottle?
好吧，这下说得通了。他们把 marinara（意大利番茄酱）列为调味品。它增强风味。每样东西都增强风味。洋葱增强风味。每样东西都增强风味。洋葱增强风味。大蒜。它必须是……你必须把它从瓶子里挤出来吗？
Does it have to be, yeah. Does it have to be in something? What is a condiment? I need more information. We need more information on condiments. Hold on. Is jelly a condiment? Jelly and jam are usually viewed as condiments,
它必须是，是的。它必须装在什么容器里吗？什么是调味品？我需要更多信息。我们需要关于调味品的更多信息。等等。果冻是调味品吗？果冻和果酱通常被视为调味品，
but peanut butter is not. Salsa is considered a condiment, but guacamole is not. Here's what I'm thinking. Condiments either have to be something you sprinkle or kind of more of a liquidy form. Not according to Wikipedia, which says a condiment is a supplemental food such as a sauce or powder. Ha!
但花生酱不是。萨尔萨辣酱被认为是调味品，但鳄梨酱不是。我是这么想的。调味品要么是你撒上去的东西，要么是更偏向液体状的东西。维基百科可不这么说，维基百科说调味品是诸如酱汁或粉末之类的补充食品。哈！
Sprinkle and liquid. That supports my theory. If it's more of a solid substance, it's not a condiment. If you can sprinkle it or pour it, it's a condiment. If you can chop it, it's not a condiment. Sprinkle and pour. All right. Are we ready to move on from the condiments? Maybe. Oh, no. Oh my God, you're making a lot of, hmm. It sounds like, you know what, Joanne?
撒上去的和液体的。这支持了我的理论。如果它是更固体的物质，它就不是调味品。如果你能撒上去或者倒出来，它就是调味品。如果你得切碎它，它就不是调味品。撒和倒。好了。我们准备好从调味品这个话题走出来了吗？也许吧。哦，不。哦，天哪，你发出了好多“嗯”的声音。听起来，你知道吗，乔安妮？
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. When you do that, hmm, it means you disagree. Like, hmm. Icing. Icing is a condiment? So when I'm eating a cupcake, I'm eating cake with a condiment on top? Makes sense to me. Really? Jenna's doing it. Hmm.
对不起。对不起。对不起。当你发出那种声音，嗯，这意味着你不同意。比如，嗯。糖霜。糖霜是调味品？所以当我吃纸杯蛋糕时，我是在吃上面带有调味品的蛋糕？我觉得这说得通。真的吗？珍娜正在这样做。嗯。
I knew it. If you're ever in a conversation with Jenna, she goes, hmm. It means she is slightly judging you and disagrees. Well Wikipedia says peanut butter is a condiment, so clearly. I don't know. Clearly there's a debate. So Dwight has put a bunch of random condiments on the counter.
我就知道。如果你在跟珍娜对话，她发出“嗯”的声音。这意味着她微微在评判你并且不同意你的观点。好吧，维基百科说花生酱是调味品，所以很显然。我不知道。很显然这里有争论。所以德怀特在台面上放了一堆随机的调味品。
He has. And I have nowhere to go from there. That's the end. Move on. He clearly isn't intending on doing anything with them. He's just doing busy work so he can set up Jim to fail. Next up, Michael and Erin are going to arrive at the high school.
他确实放了。我从那以后就没话可说了。就这样结束了。继续。他显然不打算用它们做什么。他只是在假装忙碌，好为给吉姆挖坑做准备。接下来，迈克尔和艾琳将抵达高中。
And I have a little location breakdown for you. Fan question from Cyrus in Bloomfield, Michigan. Were the school scenes filmed at a local LA school? Yes, they were. We shot the interiors and exteriors at Van Nuys Middle School, which is a steam magnet school on Vesper Avenue in Van Nuys, California. We were there for two days, Monday and Tuesday, October 3rd and 4th. By the way, this is also where they shot the school location for the TV show Fresh Off the Boat. Well, I had a recurring guest star on Fresh Off the Boat. Do you know if you ever went to the school?
我有一个关于外景的小盘点。来自密歇根州布卢姆addField的赛鲁斯（Cyrus）的粉丝提问：学校的场景是在当地的洛杉矶学校拍摄的吗？是的，确实是。我们在范奈司中学（Van Nuys Middle School）拍摄了室内和室外，这是一所位于加利福尼亚州范奈司维斯帕大道（Vesper Avenue）的科学技术工程艺术数学（STEAM）磁石学校。我们在那里待了两天，周一和周二，10月3rd和4th。顺便说一下，这也是他们拍摄电视剧《初来乍到》（Fresh Off the Boat）学校外景的地方。好吧，我在《初来乍到》里演过一个常驻客串明星。你知道你有没有去过那所学校吗？
I think we did one day because I was at a PTA meeting. I was like the mean lady shocker. Well, there's a lot of great little details at this school. Phil Shea outdid himself. I loved the plaque that said Michael Garry Scott reading room. And Aaron's like, you're famous. Yes. Michael has cold feet about seeing everyone, but Michaela greets them and insists they
我想我们去过一天，因为我在开家长会。我就像是那个刻薄的坏女人，太惊人了。好吧，这所学校里有很多很棒的小细节。菲利斯·谢伊（Phil Shea）真是超常发挥。我喜欢那个写着“迈克尔·加里·斯科特阅览室”的牌匾。艾琳说，你太出名了。是的。迈克尔在见到大家之前有些临阵退缩，但米凯拉（Michaela）迎了上来，坚持说他们
just want to give them a big thank you. I know. Michaela was played by Ishiba Renee. She posted on Instagram that she still has her shirt from this episode. Oh, she got to keep her Scott's Tots shirt. That's so cool. She was so good. And she is going to lead Michael into this classroom full of kids, all wearing Scott's Tots shirts.
只是想向他表达巨大的感谢。我知道。米凯拉由伊什巴·雷妮（Ishiba Renee）扮演。她在Instagram上发文说，她还保留着这一集里的衬衫。哦，她留下了她的“斯科特 Tots”衬衫。太酷了。她演得太好了。她将带领迈克尔走进这个满是穿着“斯科特 Tots”衬衫的孩子的教室。
I mean, huge applause. They're so excited he's there. We find out that they have prepared something for him, which is a song and dance routine. We had a fan question from Harmjian V in the Netherlands. The dance routine of the Tots is awesome. Where did you find these actors' dancers? And Lisa from New Jersey asked who choreographed the dance routine. Well, Randy Cordray shared with us that the choreographer was
我的意思是，掌声雷动。他们太高兴他能来了。我们发现他们为他准备了节目，那就是歌舞表演。我们收到了来自荷兰的哈姆詹·V（Harmjian V）的粉丝提问。Tots们的舞蹈表演太棒了。你们在哪里找到这些演员兼舞者的？来自新泽西州的丽莎（Lisa）询问是谁编排的舞蹈。好吧，兰迪·科德雷跟我们分享说，编舞是
Tony Gonzalez, and he had done choreography for Bring It On Again and Bring It On All or Nothing. You know, he's currently doing the choreography for the Masked Singer. And he cast the eight specialty dancers. The dancers were Danielle E. Hawkins, Glenda Morales, David Eisel, Katrina Norman, Chris Moss, Oscar Orozco, Jonathan Rice, and Quentin Burdette. We only had two days of rehearsals with the dancers. They set up a rehearsal space over on our warehouse stage. They were so good. They were so good.
托尼·冈萨雷斯，他曾为《魅力克星》和《魅力克星：全部或无》做过编舞。你知道，他目前正在为《蒙面歌王》担任编舞。他挑选了八位专业舞者。这些舞者是丹妮尔·E·霍金斯、格伦达·莫拉莱斯、大卫·艾塞尔、卡特里娜·诺曼、克里斯·莫斯、奥斯卡·奥罗斯科、乔纳森·赖斯和昆廷·伯德特。我们和舞者们只有两天的排练时间。他们在我们的仓库舞台那边搭建了一个排练场地。他们太棒了。他们真的太棒了。
There's no way in a million years that I could learn anything like that in two days. No. It's just a gift. You just have it. You know, I danced growing up. There was a time when I could do that. That time is not now anymore. I tried during the pandemic to take up my tap dancing again.
我有一百万年的时间也不可能在两天内学会那样的事情。不可能。这简直是一种天赋。你就是有这种能力。你知道的，我从小就跳舞。曾经有一段时间我能做到。那个时代现在已经一去不复返了。我在疫情期间尝试过重新捡起我的踢踏舞。
I got a little tap dance floor. I remember this. And I was tapping. And I thought, I'm going to learn a tap routine to footloose. Oh. And like, you got to cut loose. Yeah.
我弄了一小块踢踏舞地板。我还记得这个。我在那儿跳踢踏舞。然后我想，我要学一段配合《浑身是劲》的踢踏舞。哦。就像，你得解放天性。对。
OK. And I found like an instructional video on YouTube. And I was like, this is going to be great. It's going to be so fun. I mean, it was like 45 seconds long. Weeks. Weeks I spent on this very beginner tap routine. I never posted it.
好的。然后我在油管上找到了一个教学视频。当时我想，这肯定棒极了。这一定老有趣了。我的意思是，它大概只有45秒长。几个星期。我花了好几个星期在这段非常初级的踢踏舞上。我从来没发过它。
I have like a gazillion videos of myself in my garage on my tap floor. Can I please see one? Can I please put it in Pod Stories? Not to laugh at you! Not to laugh at you! To laugh with me because I was not even laughing yet! So, someone's laughing. Maybe.
我车库里的踢踏舞地板上拍了我自己的好家伙，无数个视频。我能看一个吗？我能把它放进《播客故事》里吗？不是为了嘲笑你！不是为了嘲笑你！是一起笑，因为我当时甚至都还没笑呢！所以，有人在笑。也许吧。
Maybe. Okay. Well, I thought the dancers did a fantastic job. They did. We also had a fan question from Laura in Warren, Ohio who said, who wrote the song, Hey Mr. Scott? Well, Lee and Gene wrote the lyrics for the song, and Eve Nelson wrote the music. Eve is an Emmy-winning composer who did a lot of specialty work for us, such
也许吧。好吧，我觉得舞者们表现得太棒了。他们的确很棒。我们还有一个来自俄亥俄州沃伦市劳拉的粉丝提问，她说，是谁写的歌《嘿，斯科特先生》？好吧，李和吉恩为这首歌写了歌词，伊芙·纳尔逊写了曲子。伊芙是一位获得过艾美奖的作曲家，她为我们做过很多特色工作，比如
as composing the music for Subtle Sexuality, the webisode. The one we listened to last week. Yes, that Mindy sings. She also did all the music for Threat Level Midnight. I thought we should hear an audio clip of Hey Mr. Scott. Ooh. Hey Mr. Scott, what you gonna do? What you gonna do? Make our dreams come true.
为网络剧《微妙的性取向》谱曲。也就是我们上周听的那部。是的，敏迪唱的。她还为《绝命威胁》创作了所有的音乐。我觉得我们应该听听《嘿，斯科特先生》的音频片段。哦。嘿，斯科特先生，你打算怎么做？你打算怎么做？让我们的梦想成真。
Hey Mr. Scott, what you gonna do? What you gonna do? Make our dreams come true. You came into a life that made a promise, that made us honest, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us
嘿，斯科特先生，你打算怎么做？你打算怎么做？让我们的梦想成真。你走进了一个许下诺言的人生，这诺言让我们诚实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们
real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us real, made us Hey, Mr. Scott, what you gonna do? What you gonna do? Make our dreams come true. You came into a life and made a promise that made us honest, made us realize we don't need a compromise because we can have it all. Because you made it possible for us to achieve the improbable. Hey, hey, hey, hey. Hey, Mr. Scott, what you gonna do? What you gonna do? Make our dreams come true. So good, Eve Nelson. Eve, coming through again.
真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们真实，让我们嘿，斯科特先生，你打算怎么做？你打算怎么做？让我们的梦想成真。你走进了一个生活，许下一个承诺，让我们诚实，让我们意识到我们不需要妥协，因为我们可以拥有一切。因为你让我们有可能实现不可思议的事情。嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿。嘿，斯科特先生，你打算怎么做？你打算怎么做？让我们的梦想成真。太棒了，伊芙·纳尔逊。伊芙，再次惊艳全场。
And I can't wait now to see Threat Level Midnight. I know and see all that music. It's funny that you bring up the webisodes because just last week we were talking about it, but I also mentioned the bobbleheads last week that Joya Balfour, who worked for NBC.com, was going to bring all these bobbleheads to the set, right? Yeah. For me to feature in Adventures with Angela. And I'm excited to be here.
我现在等不及要看《绝命威胁》了。我懂，还要看所有的音乐。你提起网络剧太有意思了，因为就在上周我们还在讨论它，但我也在上周提到了大头娃娃，为NBC.com工作的乔亚·巴尔福要把所有这些大头娃娃带到片场，对吧？是的。让我在《安吉拉大冒险》中出镜。我很高兴能来到这里。
I'm excited to be here. I'm excited to be here. I'm excited to be here. I'm excited to be here. I'm excited to be here. I'm excited to be here. I'm excited to be here. I'm excited to be here.
我很高兴能来到这里。我很高兴能来到这里。我很高兴能来到这里。我很高兴能来到这里。我很高兴能来到这里。我很高兴能来到这里。我很高兴能来到这里。我很高兴能来到这里。
I'm excited to be here. I'm excited to be here. I'm excited to be here. I'm excited to be here. I'm excited to be here. I'm excited to be here. bobbleheads last week that Joya Balfour, who worked for NBC.com, was going to bring all these bobbleheads to the set, right? Yeah. For me to feature in Adventures with Angela. Lady, on set that day, she said, Angela, would you like all of these bobbleheads? Like you're going to have one of all the cast members since you're doing this for us. And I said, oh my God, I would.
我很高兴能来到这里。我很高兴能来到这里。我很高兴能来到这里。我很高兴能来到这里。我很高兴能来到这里。我很高兴能来到这里。上周提到的那些大头娃娃，为NBC.com工作的乔亚·巴尔福要把所有这些大头娃娃带到片场，对吧？是的。让我在《安吉拉大冒险》中出镜。姑娘，那天在片场，她说，安吉拉，你想要所有这些大头娃娃吗？鉴于你正在为我们做这个，你将拥有所有演员的大头娃娃。我说，噢天哪，我当然想要。
And she goes, okay, let me see. But I think I can get you a whole set of full cast member bobbleheads. And I was like, oh, that'll be so fun. Maybe I'll like line them like on a shelf in my house. That is so cool. Do you have them? Okay. So here's the thing. Years ago, she was like, Angela, I got the bobbleheads for you. When do you want them? And I was moving and I was like, oh, I'm moving right now. Can we figure out? And Jenna, I don't know. Life happened. Years went by. Joy reached out to me and said, Angela, I've had these bobbleheads for 15 years. What?
她说，好的，让我看看。但我想我可以给你弄一整套全演员阵容的大头娃娃。我当时想，哦，那太有趣了。也许我会把它们排在我家里的书架上。那太酷了。你有它们吗？好吧。事情是这样的。几年前，她说，安吉拉，我给你弄到大头娃娃了。你什么时候想要？当时我正在搬家，我说，哦，我正忙着搬家呢。我们能回头再商量吗？珍娜，我不知道。生活中的事接踵而至。几年过去了。乔亚联系我说，安吉拉，这十五年来我一直留着这些大头娃娃。什么？
Like just recently she reached out. Yeah. She's like, they're in boxes. Can I bring them to you? I said, oh my gosh, Joya. Yes. So we met for coffee and we caught up 15 years of life and marriage and kids. And Jenna, she opened up her trunk and it was full of bobbleheads.
就像不久前她联系我一样。是的。她说，它们都在盒子里。我能给你带过去吗？我说，哦天哪，乔亚。太好了。于是我们见面喝咖啡，叙旧了十五年来各自的生活、婚姻和孩子。珍娜，她打开后备箱，里面装满了大头娃娃。
I took a picture of her standing by her trunk. I now have all of these bobbleheads. That is so crazy because you know when we were going through all of our bins of stuff for the book, I found an Oscar bobblehead and a Jim bobblehead and a Pam bobblehead and a Dwight bobblehead. That's all I have. I will tell you the bobble head I didn't know I need, but I definitely needed was Phyllis. Oh, is Phyllis is good? Phyllis is so great.
我拍了一张她站在后备箱旁边的照片。我现在拥有了所有这些大头娃娃。这太疯狂了，因为你知道当我们为这本书翻找所有杂物箱时，我发现了一个奥斯卡大头娃娃、一个吉姆大头娃娃、一个帕姆大头娃娃和一个德怀特大头娃娃。这就是我所有的了。我得告诉你我之前不知道自己需要、但绝对需要的那个大头娃娃是菲莉丝。哦，菲莉丝的好看吗？菲莉丝太棒了。
Joy went on to tell me while we were having coffee, she said, you know, it's kind of crazy. I've had all these bobble heads, but I also have something that I think a lot of people wanted, but I ended up getting. And I was like, do tell. Guess who has the original Unicorn Barbie? What?
乔亚接着在喝咖啡的时候告诉我，她说，你知道，这有点疯狂。我一直留着所有这些大头娃娃，但我还有一样东西，我想很多人都想要，但最终被我得到了。我当时就说，快告诉我。猜猜谁有原版的独角兽芭比？什么？
Yes. And here's Joya sharing about it. The story of how I acquired the Princess Unicorn Barbie doll is really fun. I of course was a digital producer for the show working at NBC. And I had read the script for Moroccan Christmas, the episode that it appeared in, and I wanted to use it for our Dunder Mifflin Infinity virtual game. And I also wanted to build a website for Princess Unicorn,
是的。以下是乔亚分享的经历。我获得公主独角兽芭比娃娃的故事真的很有趣。我当然是NBC该剧的网络制片人。我读过《摩洛哥圣诞节》的剧本，也就是它出场的那集，我想把它用在我们的邓德米夫林无限虚拟游戏中。我还想为公主独角兽建立一个网站，
because it seemed like this crazy, funny thing that a little website would just be hilarious for. If you're a big fan of the show, you know that we did a ton of these little one off websites all the time. So princess unicorn doll.com was one of them. And what's really interesting is that NBC let the domain expire some years ago and someone bought it up and kept the exact same website there. So you can actually go see the website and thank you to whoever bought
因为这听起来像是一件疯狂而有趣的事情，给它做一个小网站一定会非常搞笑。如果你是该剧的超级粉丝，你就会知道我们一直都在做大量这种一次性的小网站。所以 princess unicorn doll.com 就是其中之一。非常有趣的是，NBC 在几年前让这个域名过期了，然后有人把它买下来，保留了完全相同的网站。所以你其实还可以去参观那个网站，感谢买下它并保留了这个网站的人。我很感激。所以我想把它用在游戏中。如果你在玩这个游戏，它是一个你可以为你的邓德米夫林办公室购买的虚拟物品，而且是一个非常罕见的物品。所以道具部门实际上把这个娃娃送给了我。他们制作了两个版本的娃娃，他们给了我一个，让我在NBC的办公室里拍照。所以我照做了，不管出于什么原因，剧组里没有人向我要回这个娃娃。后来剧结束了，大家都各奔东西。我最终也离开了NBC，这个娃娃就跟着我一起走了，
that and kept the same website up. I appreciate you. So I wanted to use it for the game. It was a virtual item that you could purchase for your Dunder Mifflin office if you were playing the game and it was a very rare item. So the props department actually gave the doll to me. They had two versions of the doll that they made and they gave me one to photograph back at my office at NBC. So I did that, and for whatever reason, no one at the show asked me for the doll back. And the show ended, and everyone went on their separate ways. And I eventually left NBC, and this doll came with me,
它一直留在我家里，作为来自该剧的一种珍贵纪念品。你知道的，将近10年了，我一直拥有这个娃娃。这是来自该剧的一件纪念品。我想我永远都不会放弃它，因为它是如此的神奇。这就是我的公主独角兽娃娃的故事。我简直不敢相信她有一个原版的。总共只有两个，她居然有一个。好吧，现在我知道如何获得原版道具了。
and it's been in my house as this kind of prized memento from the show. You know, for almost 10 years, I've had this doll. It's the one memento from the show. I don't think I will ever give up because it's it's pretty amazing. So that is my Princess Unicorn doll story. I cannot believe she has one of the original. There were only two and she has one of them. Well, now I know how to get original props.
你必须像这样，你知道吗？我很想做一个网站，但我需要那个东西来拍照。然后我只需要等着你们来要回它。如果你们不开口，那它就是我的了。这太神奇了。太神奇了。见到乔亚真好。乔亚，非常感谢你的大头娃娃。
You have to be like, you know what? I'd love to build a website, but I'm going to need that to photograph it. And then I'm going to just wait for you to ask for it back. And if you don't, you don't. That is amazing. Amazing. It was so good to see, Joya. And Joya, thank you so much for the bobbleheads.
我得把它们展示出来给你们看。好了，说正事，我们休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将去看看德怀特。看看他在忙些什么。然后，哦天哪。好吧，迈克尔有一个重大消息要宣布。他确实有。德怀特现在到处去收钱。
I'll have to display them and show you guys. Well, on that note, let's take a break. And when we come back, we'll check in on Dwight. We'll see what he's up to. And then, oh boy. Well, Michael has a big announcement to make. He does. Dwight is now going around collecting money.
他从凯文开始，应吉姆的要求，每人出20美元凑钱作为月度员工的奖励。奥斯卡也捐了。他不需要德怀特的演讲。在整个过程中，你猜谁在玩纸牌接龙？我看到了。我又一次看到了。在她的飞地纸牌游戏上积极地移动着纸牌。凯特·弗兰内利在背景里扮演着梅雷迪思，正在玩一局非常快的纸牌接龙。听着，德怀特的计划比预定时间提前了五分钟。完全按计划进行。嗯哼。
He starts with Kevin, 20 bucks to chip in for employee of the month per Jim's request. Oscar contributes as well. He doesn't need Dwight's speech. During this whole moment, guess who's playing solitaire? I saw it. I saw it once again. Actively moving cards on her free sell game. Kate Flannery in the background is Meredith playing a very quick game of solitaire. Listen, Dwight's plan is five minutes ahead of schedule. Right on schedule. Mm-hmm.
它正在起效。回到学校，一位老师站在教室前面，她正在万分感激迈克尔兑现了送这些孩子上学的承诺。是的。然后一个学生站起来说，基本上，你是我的守护天使。迈克尔在哭。哦，天哪。
It's working. Back at the school, a teacher is up at the front of the room and she is profusely thanking Michael for following through on his promise to send these kids to school. Yeah. And then a student gets up and says, basically, you're my guardian angel. Michael is crying. Oh, boy.
这太符合迈克尔的风格了。他们编写这个场景层层递进的方式太棒了，因为每发生一件事，你都会感觉胸口重重地挨了一脚。然后以迈克尔收尾。发表这段感谢演讲的女士由莫妮·麦凯尔饰演。希望我没有念错你的名字。她太棒了。
It's just Michael. The way they wrote the scene to build is so great Because with each thing, you're getting just a kick to the stomach. And then it ends with Michael. The woman who's giving this thank you speech was played by Monet McKell. I hope I'm saying your name right. She's amazing.
她以音乐剧演员的身份开始了自己的职业生涯。她曾获得 NAACP 戏剧奖提名。她还在一个获奖的独角戏中表演过。她还在《善地》和《捍卫者联盟》中饰演过常驻角色，以及大量其他电影和电视角色。好吧，她为这个场景设定了很高的基准，因为它是如此发自内心，她的感激之情，理应如此，因为你要送这些孩子们去上大学。就像，场景开始时的那种责任感，简直让人觉得，哦，糟了。
She began her career as a musical theater actress. She has been nominated for an NAACP Theater Award. And she performed in an award-winning one-woman show. She's also had recurring roles on The Good Place and The Defenders, as well as a ton of other film and television roles. Well, she set the bar for this scene because it's so heartfelt, her appreciation, as you would be because you're sending these kids to college. Like, the level of accountability that the scene starts with is like, oh, crap.
迈克尔，哦，迈克尔。好吧，轮到迈克尔发言了。就是这个时刻。是的。人群在欢呼。迈克尔说他永远不会忘记今天。哦，然后他让孩子们举手示意。他想知道，你们当中有多少人
Michael, oh, Michael. Well, it's Michael's turn to speak. This is the moment. Yeah. The crowd is cheering. Michael says he'll never forget today. Oh, and then he asks the kids for a show of hands. He wants to know, how many of you the kids for a show of hands. He wants to know how many of you
犯过愚蠢的错误。在宣布这个糟糕的消息之前，他试图把他们拉到自己这边。我当时觉得我们需要听听看。哦不，真的吗？我不知道。哦天哪，哦天哪。好吧，此刻我就是帕姆。好吧，听着。
have ever made a stupid mistake. He's trying to get them on his side before giving them this terrible news. I kind of thought we needed to hear it. Oh no, really? I don't know. Oh God, oh God. All right, in this moment I'm a Pam. Okay, let's hear it.
我今天来这里是因为我承诺过你们学费。而学费是非常宝贵的。但你知道什么才是无价的吗？是直觉。你知道那是什么吗？那就是知道某事即将发生的本领。外面的大家有谁有直觉吗？知道接下来会发生什么？
I came here today because I promised you tuition. And tuition is very valuable. But you know what's invaluable? Is intuition. You know what that is? That is the ability to know when something is about to happen. Does anybody out there have intuition? Know what's going gonna happen next?
没有人吗？好吧。你们非要逼我说出来。好吧。我为你们所有感到骄傲。德里克、拉费夫、本、阿扬娜、米凯拉、尼基、杰森还有我很抱歉，好吧。抱歉记错了你们的名字。我是锡安，米凯拉的弟弟。
Nobody? Okay. You're gonna make me say it. All right. I am so proud of all of you. Derek and LaFerve and Ben and Ayanna and Michaela and Nicky and Jason and I'm sorry, okay. Sorry for spacing your name. I'm Zion, I'm Michaela's younger brother.
好吧，锡安，我不会为你的学费买单。这就引出了我的核心观点，那就是我将无法为任何人的学费买单。我真的很抱歉。听着，我——我为所有那些错过《斯科特小鬼》的人感到遗憾。我刚刚给你们播放了最糟糕的部分。你知道的，最让人脚趾抠地的部分。
Well, Zion, I am not going to be paying for your tuition. Which brings me to my main point, and that is that I will not be able to pay for anybody's tuition. I'm so, so sorry. Listen, I- I'm sorry for all the people out there who skip Scott's Tots. I just played the worst part for you. You know, the cringiest part.
我看这一集看了三遍。这通常是我每周为播客做准备时观看一集的次数。我现在可能需要从它里面缓一缓。他接着试图当一个英雄。我们和B.J.讨论过这个。他让亚伦推着这个巨大的行李箱进来，你以为里面会装满笔记本电脑，这算是一种救赎，一台笔记本电脑，不是大学学费，而是一台笔记本电脑，但并没有，里面装的只是笔记本电脑的锂电池。
I watched this episode three times. That's usually how many times I watch an episode as we prep each week for the podcast. And I might need a break from it now. He goes on to try to be a hero. We talked about this with BJ. He has Aaron wheel in this humongous suitcase, which you think are going to be filled with laptops, which is some saving grace, a laptop, not college tuition, but a laptop, but no, it's just the lithium batteries for a laptop.
伙计们，那些都是假电池。在14分46秒的时候，笔记本电脑电池盒的图形是由我们的平面设计师亨利·塞恩创作的，并由菲尔·谢伊打包。假电池。假电池。好吧，回到办公室，吉姆即将迎来他自己的脚趾抠地时刻。我喜欢他们剪辑这些场景的方式，因为你从迈克尔陷入水深火热直接过渡到吉姆陷入水深火热。
Guys, those are fakey batteries. At 14 minutes, 46 seconds, the graphics for the laptop battery boxes were created by our graphic designer, Henry Sane, and packaged up by Phil Shea. Fakey batteries. Fakey battery. Well, back at the office, Jim's about to have his own cringe moment. I love how they edited these scenes because you go from Michael being in hot water to Jim being in hot water.
是的。吉姆将根据这些数据宣布月度员工。这是9号员工。谁是9号员工？是吉姆。哦天哪。人们瞬间怒了。他们甚至都没有停顿一下来想想，哦，也许是个错误。
Yes. Jim is going to announce the employee of the month according to this data. It's employee number nine. Who is employee number nine? It's Jim. Oh boy. People are instantly furious. They don't even take a beat to be like, oh, maybe there was an error.
不，他们瞬间就反应过来：是你！是的，吉姆赢了一千美元！对，还得到了他自己的专属停车位。哦天哪。他说，不，不，不，这显然是个错误。名单上的第二名是谁？我们需要名单上的第二个人。哦哦。
No, they're instantly like, you! Yes, Jim won $1,000! Yeah, and got his own parking spot. Oh my gosh. He's like, no, no, no, this is obviously a mistake. Who's second on the list? We need the second person on the list. Uh oh.
是吉姆的妻子，帕姆。哦天哪。这怎么可能？但帕姆要为自己作为赢家进行辩护。是的，她就像，等等，拜访。我一天都没缺勤。我来得早。我走得晚，而且我上个月的销售额翻倍了。
It's Jim's wife, Pam. Oh boy. How is that even possible? But Pam is going to defend herself as the winner. Yeah, she's like, no wait, come on. I didn't miss a day. I came in early. I stayed late and I doubled my sales last month.
安迪说，哦真的吗？从两单到四单？没错。那是你最著名的表情包之一。我把它发给过别人。我把我自己的表情包发给别人，那个“没错”。我给别人发过安吉拉翻白眼的表情包，用的是我自己的表情包。
Andy goes, oh really? From what? Two to four? Yup. That is one of your most famous memes. I have texted it to people. I texted my own meme to people, the yup. I have texted an Angela I roll to people, my own meme.
我到处都能看到那个“没错”，珍娜。我知道。而且它太完美了。它逗笑了我。尽管我很清楚，它还是把我逗笑了。我在做这个表情的时候就把自己逗笑了。你会惊讶于只说一个词而不笑场竟然这么难。
I see that yup everywhere, Jenna. I know. And it's so perfect. It made me laugh. Even though I know it, it still made me laugh. It made me laugh while I was doing it. You'd be surprised how difficult it was to get just one word without me breaking.
没错。好吧，情况会变得更糟。你以为对吉姆来说不会更糟糕了，但现在会送来一个印有他脸的蛋糕。这是一个真正的蛋糕，伙计们。我们真的吃这个蛋糕了。我们吃了。我吃了一片。
Yup. Well, it's going to get even worse. You think it can't get worse for Jim, but now there's going to be a cake delivered with his face on it. This was a real cake, you guys. We actually ate this cake. We did. I had a slice of it.
它很好吃。那是一个约翰的脸部角度非常扭曲的蛋糕。确实有点。就像有人给你拍照时让你把下巴抬高一样。那天我在片场确实拿着相机拍下了那个蛋糕的照片。我会把它发到故事里。蛋糕派送员由查理·桑德斯饰演，他是一位编剧、演员，也是《基与皮尔》的联合制片人，他曾连续三年获得艾美奖杰出编剧提名。
It was delicious. It was a real distorted angle of John's face. It was a little bit. It was like when someone takes a photo of you and they go like chin up. I actually had my camera on set that day and I took a picture of the cake. I'll put it in stories. The Cake Delivery Man was played by Charlie Sanders, who is a writer, actor, and co-producer of Key and Peel, for which he was nominated for an Emmy for Outstanding Writing three years in a row.
我喜欢《基与皮尔》。我也是。哦天哪，他们笑死我了。我们和《基与皮尔》一起玩过。我们确实一起玩过。我们和他们一起坐过私人飞机。我唯一一次坐私人飞机。好吧，我也是。是的，
I love Key and Peel. Me too. Oh my God, it cracks me up. We hung out with Key and Peel. We did. We were on a private plane with them. The only time I've ever been on a private plane. Well, same. Yes,
凯撒宫殿邀请珍娜、科甘和乔丹去参加这个扑克锦标赛。你带我作为你的女伴去的。他们用私人飞机把我们送到新奥尔良。我们在飞机上和这些家伙一起玩尤克牌玩了整个航程。我喜欢尤克牌。我们简直不敢相信其他人也知道尤克牌。那是一种纸牌游戏。我们很喜欢他们。他们太有趣了。这个蛋糕并不是德怀特的恶魔计划清单上的最后一项。不，他把所有人都煽动起来了。但这只有在人们向大卫·华莱士抱怨时才管用。
Caesar Palace flew Jenna and Keegan and Jordan to play in this poker tournament. You took me as a plus one. They flew us to New Orleans. We got on this private plane with these guys and we played euchre the whole plane ride. I love euchre. We couldn't believe other people knew euchre. It's a card game. We love them. They're so fun. The cake is not the last thing on Dwight's list of diabolical plans. No, he riles everybody up. But it only works if people complain to David Wallace.
所以德怀特开始给大卫·华莱士的办公室打电话，假装成其他人。这太棒了。我其实觉得我们需要听听看。他将以凯文、斯坦利和托比的身份留下留言。我觉得我最喜欢的部分是他的肢体语言。发生了变化。当他模仿所有的声音时，当他是托比时，他用指尖绕着自己的头发。是的。他整个人瘫倒在地上。是的。但就是这样。你必须听听。
So Dwight starts calling David Wallace's office, pretending to be everyone else. It's so good. I actually, I thought we needed to hear it. He is going to leave messages as Kevin, as Stanley, and as Toby. I think my favorite part is like his body language. Changes. As he's doing all the voice, he's like spinning his hair with his fingertip when he's being Toby. Yeah. He's like all slumped on the ground. Yeah. But here it is. you have to hear it. Hudson. Jim Halpert is a man-ass. It's Toby Flenderson. Listen, things are getting really bad down here. Those are so funny to me. But Jenna, there was one more.
哈德森。吉姆·哈尔珀特是个混蛋。我是托比·弗伦德森。听着，这里的情况变得真的很糟糕。这些对我来说太搞笑了。但是珍娜，还有一个。
There was? Yes. It didn't make it in the final cut, but it's in deleted scenes. It's a little R-rated, so maybe that's why it didn't make it. Here is Dwight calling pretending to be Meredith. It's Meredith Palmer. Listen, kid, I'm going to be drunk as a skunk, and you don't know anything to tell me about crotch injuries. But Jim Halpert is a f***ing prick. Oh my gosh! I know! So imagine David Wallace getting all of these messages.
还有吗？是的。它没有进入最终剪辑，但在删减片段里。它有点限制级，所以也许这就是它没能入选的原因。这是德怀特假装成梅雷迪思打来的电话。我是梅雷迪思·帕尔默。听着，孩子，我要烂醉如泥，关于腹股沟受伤的事，你什么也教不了我。但吉姆·哈尔珀特是个他妈的混蛋。哦天哪！我知道！所以想象一下大卫·华莱士接到所有这些留言时的情景。
Yeah, Jim is definitely going to be hearing from David Wallace later. But back at the school, Michael and Erin are leaving. They are disgraced. But as they're leaving, one of the students runs out and just kind of confronts Michael. He's like, dude, this is like really messed up. And Michael just apologizes again and he says, you know what, I'll pay for your books. It's the least I can do. Yeah.
是的，吉姆绝对会在晚些时候接到大卫·华莱士的电话。但回到学校，迈克尔和艾琳正要离开。他们名誉扫地。但就在他们离开时，其中一个学生跑出来质问迈克尔。他说，老兄，这真的太操蛋了。迈克尔只是再次道歉并说道，你知道吗，我来为你付书本费。这是我能做的最起码的事了。是的。
And he's like, okay, well, books are like $1,000. I mean, that's a lot. And Michael's like, that's like, oh, $200 a year. And the kid's like, it's a thousand dollars a year. So Michael writes a few checks for a thousand dollars. He says, please notify me before you cash these. I have to move some money around. Yes. And he has to hold them for like a couple of years, each one per year. Well, listen, the actor who played the student is so good. His name is Kwame Bwateng. He is part of a trio, an acting trio. His brothers, they're referred to as the K brothers. He's amazing. He did a bunch of films and television, but now he
然后他说，好吧，书本费大概要1000美元。我的意思是，这可真不少。迈克尔就说，那大概是，哦，一年200美元。那个孩子就说，是一千美元一年。所以迈克尔写了几张一千美元的支票。他说，在你们兑现这些之前请通知我。我得腾出一笔资金。是的。而且他必须把它们压上好几年，每年兑现一张。好吧，听吧，扮演那个学生的演员太棒了。他的名字叫夸梅·博滕。他是一个三人组的成员，一个演艺三人组。他的兄弟们，被称为K兄弟。他太棒了。他拍过很多电影和电视剧，但现在他
is actually the CEO of his own company called the Bwateng Group. Wow. Yeah. So he's kind of moving and shaking in the Boitain Group. Wow. Yeah. So he's kind of moving and shaking in the business world now. And we also had a fan catch in this scene from Matthew in Franklin, Indiana. At 16 minutes, 48 seconds, you can see snow outside the school. Oh, yeah, fakie snow. Well, that fakie snow was provided by our special effects
实际上是他自己公司博滕集团的首席执行官。哇。是的。所以他现在在商业界风生水起。而且我们在这个场景中还有一个来自印第安纳州富兰克林的马修的粉丝抓包。在16分48秒时，你能看到学校外面有雪。哦，是的，假雪。好吧，那场假雪是由我们的特效
technician, Mike Thompson. According to Randy Cordray, it was actually a warm and sunny day in Van Nuys, about 75 degrees, but we threw down some fakie snow. Back in Jim's office, he does get a very frustrated call from David Wallace. I think we need to point out at 18 minutes, 7 seconds, the Phoebe Snow is back. It is? The train painting is in Jim's office. The Phoebe Snow is back.
技术员迈克·汤普森提供的。据兰迪·科德雷所说，范奈斯那天其实是一个温暖晴朗的日子，大约有75华氏度，但我们还是铺了一些假雪。回到吉姆的办公室，他确实接到了大卫·华莱士打来的一个非常沮丧的电话。我觉得我们需要指出在18分7秒时，菲比·雪景画又回来了。是吗？那幅火车画又挂在吉姆的办公室里了。菲比·雪景画回来了。
That is so weird that it was missing for one episode. I don't know. Or maybe it's just the way they angled the camera. Maybe you just couldn't see it and I thought it was missing. Well it's back. And did it make your heart happy? It really did. You know, lady, if you love trains, you should play this board game called Ticket to Ride.
它缺席了一集，这太奇怪了。我不知道。或者也许只是因为他们调整了摄像机角度。也许你只是没看到它，而我以为它不见了。好吧，它回来了。这有没有让你的心感到高兴？确实有。你知道的，女士，如果你喜欢火车，你应该玩一款叫做《车票之旅》的桌面游戏。
I love Ticket to Ride. I know Ticket to Ride. Oh, we just discovered Ticket to Ride. Our friends sent it to us and now my kids are obsessed. Yeah. You've known about Ticket to Ride all this time? I was going to gift it to you. I'm glad you told me you have it.
我喜欢《车票之旅》。我知道《车票之旅》。哦，我们刚刚发现了《车票之旅》。我们的朋友把它寄给了我们，现在我的孩子们沉迷其中。是的。你一直都知道《车票之旅》吗？我本打算把它当礼物送给你的。我很高兴你告诉我你已经有了。
Oh, yeah. Okay. We love games at my house. You know, we're big family game night folks. This was combining two of your loves, trains and a game. We also really love the Oregon Trail, old school board game version, not the computer version we grew up on. Now according to your deep dive last week, would a covered wagon be considered a limousine?
哦，对。好的。我们家很喜欢游戏。你知道的，我们很热衷于家庭游戏之夜。这结合了你的两个最爱：火车和一个游戏。我们其实也很喜欢《俄勒冈之旅》，老式桌游版的，不是我们小时候玩的电脑版。现在根据你上周的深度剖析，有篷马车能算作加长轿车吗？
Separation of driver and... Because the driver is separated from the... Cargo? I think a completely covered wagon would be, yes. What part of the covered wagon is uncovered? Sometimes they have a front flap that they keep open. But I mean, same in a limousine, the little zhuzhi thing goes down and up. No, I agree.
驾驶员与……的分离？因为驾驶员与……货物隔离了？我觉得完全封闭的马车应该算，是的。有篷马车的哪一部分是没遮盖的？有时它们前面有个挡板一直开着。但我的意思是，加长轿车也一样，那个小隔板升上降下的。不，我同意。
I am agreeing. This is me agreeing with you. I think a completely covered wagon with a driver outside would constitute as a limousine. Wow. Limousine. Tell like the early pioneers that they were actually taking limousines to the gold rush. They might be surprised. Back to this phone call between Jim and David, Dwight kind of overhears that it's not going
我在同意。这是我在赞同你的观点。我认为一个前面有车夫的完全封闭的有篷马车可以算作加长轿车。哇。加长轿车。告诉早期的拓荒者们，他们其实是坐着加长轿车去淘金的。他们可能会大吃一惊。回到吉姆和大卫之间的这通电话，德怀特无意中听到事情进展得并不
well, right? He's all excited. He's so excited. Jim's like, I don't know how it happened. Dwight's like, I know how it happened. Dwight goes back in there doing his little mom detective, drops a folder, grabs his spy pin that's been in there the whole time. As it turns out, this phone call that starts out angry
顺利，对吧？他兴奋极了。他太兴奋了。吉姆说，我不知道是怎么回事。德怀特说，我知道是怎么回事。德怀特回到那儿，发挥他那侦探妈妈的作风，掉下一个文件夹，抓起他一直放在那里的间谍别针。事实证明，这通一开始充满怒气的电话
ends amicably. David apologizes. He's like, look, I'm taking out some stuff on you, okay? Hey, am I gonna see you at dinner? And Dwight's like, no! I know, he forgot. Jim and David Wallace are chums. They're pals.
最后以友好结束。大卫道歉了。他说，听着，我刚才把一些气撒在你身上了，好吗？嘿，我能在晚餐时见到你吗？德怀特说，不！我懂的，他忘了。吉姆和大卫·华莱士是死党。他们是好朋友。
The final scene with Michael and Erin, they're driving back. Erin can't stop singing the song. Yeah. But then she says, you know, Michael, the principal told me that 90% of Scott's tots are on track to graduate, which is 35% higher than the rest of the school. So you know, you did do a good thing here.
迈克尔和艾琳的最后一场戏，他们在开车回去的路上。艾琳不停地唱着那首歌。是的。但接着她说，你知道吗，迈克尔，校长告诉我，90%的斯科特小学者都有望毕业，这比学校其他学生高出35%。所以你看，你在这里确实做了一件好事。
This warms Michael's heart. He hasn't always been that nice to Erin. He's kind of abrupt with her. She's not Pam, which he lets her know routinely. And he says to her, you know what, you're doing great. And he wants to know, what does she hope for? Yeah, what would she like for her future? She says she would like to be an accountant, even though she's terrible at math. I will tell you this is a great nod to the webisode series, The Mentor, where Erin tells the accounting
这温暖了迈克尔的心。他对艾琳一直不是那么好。他对她有点生硬。她不是帕姆，他经常让她知道这一点。他对她说，你知道吗，你做得很好。他想知道，她有什么愿望？是的，她对未来有什么期望？她说她想成为一名会计，尽管她数学极差。我要告诉你，这是对网络剧《导师》的一个很好的致敬，在那部剧里，艾琳告诉会计
department she wants to be an accountant. We talked about it last week and I totally clocked it when she said that. We also learned something about Kevin's story in this moment, which is he was applying for a job in the warehouse and Michael said, you know what, I have a feeling about you. I think you should be an accountant.
部门她想成为一名会计。我们上周讨论过，当她这么说的时候，我完全想起来了。我们在这一刻也了解到了关于凯文故事的一些情况，那就是他当时正在申请仓库的工作，迈克尔说，你知道吗，我对你有种感觉。我觉得你应该当会计。
Ah. Well, this episode ends with a tag. All of a sudden, Ryan appears in this episode and he finds Dwight's diabolical plan. Yeah, Dwight left it in the copier. He wants in. He wants to take Jim down. Ooh. That's how this episode ends. Well, I had a couple little tidbits that I thought I would share. I didn't know where to put these, so I'm putting them here at the end. The first was a piece of mail we got from Julia S. in Madison, Wisconsin. This is cringy.
啊。好吧，这一集在片尾彩蛋中结束。突然之间，瑞恩在这集中出场了，他发现了德怀特的邪恶计划。是的，德怀特把它忘在复印机里了。他想加入。他想扳倒吉姆。哦。这一集就这样结束了。好吧，我有一些小花絮想分享。我不知道把这些放在哪里，所以我把它们放在最后。第一条是我们收到来自威斯康星州麦迪逊市的朱莉娅·S的一封信。这真让人尴尬。
She said, I work at a nonprofit company and we had a program that ended up being a Scots Tots reincarnate. Oh no. She said the goal of the program was to encourage parents of elementary school kids to begin putting away a small amount of money every month that would go toward their kids' college tuitions. She said my company promised that if they did that, the company would give a huge scholarship to each child when they began college.
她说，我在一家非营利公司工作，我们有一个项目，结果成了现实版的“斯科特小学者”。哦不。她说这个项目的目标是鼓励小学生父母每个月存入一小笔钱，用于他们孩子的大学学费。她说我们公司承诺，如果他们照做，公司将在每个孩子上大学时给予他们一大笔奖学金。
But after a couple of years, the company decided it was too big of a promise to pay scholarships to all the kids and the program had to send out an email to let everyone know that the scholarships weren't going to happen. Oh my gosh. She said, me and my colleagues now cringe every time someone mentions this failed program and when we talk about it, we call it Scott's Tots. But I can't leave us on that note. So I wanted to leave you with this real life story called Dale's Kids. I want to hear about Dale's Kids. Dale
但几年后，公司认为向所有孩子支付奖学金的承诺太大了，该项目不得不发出电子邮件，让大家知道奖学金不会发放了。天哪。她说，每当有人提到这个失败的项目时，我和同事们都会感到尴尬，当我们谈论它时，我们叫它“斯科特小学者”。但我不能以这种情绪结束。所以我想留给你们一个名为“戴尔的孩子们”的真实故事。我想听听关于“戴尔的孩子们”的故事。戴尔
Schroeder was described in his local paper as a simple man who grew up poor, never went to college, never got married, and worked at the same business as a carpenter for 67 years. They said he had a pair of work jeans, a pair of church jeans, and a Chevy truck. When he passed away in 2005, he did not have any descendants, but after nearly 70 years of carpentry and frugal living, he had saved nearly $3 million.
施罗德在当地报纸上被描述为一个单纯的人，他家境贫寒，从未上过大学，从未结婚，作为一名木匠在同一家企业工作了67 years。他们说他只有一条工作穿的牛仔裤，一条去教堂穿的牛仔裤，还有一辆雪佛兰卡车。当他在2005年去世时，他没有留下任何后代，但经过近70年的木工工作和节俭生活，他积攒了近300万美元。
Most of that money went into a scholarship fund, which helped 33 people go to college free of charge. The kids who benefited from this scholarship all gathered recently to talk about the impact that the scholarship had on their lives. They are now doctors, teachers, a therapist. They said that the money came with only one caveat. Their request was, please pay this forward. You can't pay Dale back, but you can remember him and emulate
这笔钱大部分进入了一个奖学金基金，帮助了33人免费上大学。受惠于这笔奖学金的孩子们最近聚在一起，谈论这笔奖学金对他们生活的影响。他们现在是医生、老师、治疗师。他们说这笔钱只有一个条件。他们的要求是，请把这份爱传递下去。你无法回报戴尔，但你可以记住他并效仿
him. And that is the legacy of Dale Schroeder, and they affectionately call themselves Dale's kids. Oh, that is so lovely. Oh, Jenna, that is wonderful. Well, I had a quote to end this episode on and now I feel bad saying it because that's such a nice sentiment to end on. Well, I still want to hear your quote, lady. All right. This is from Cheatsheet.com. All right. We're taking a pivot here, folks. This is about this episode. And I quote,
他。这就是戴尔·施罗德的遗产，他们亲切地称自己为戴尔的孩子们。哦，太美好了。哦，珍娜，这太棒了。好吧，我有一句名言作为这一集的结尾，现在我觉得说出来有点不好意思，因为这是一个如此美好的结尾。好吧，我还是想听听你的名言，女士。好的。这来自Cheatsheet.com。好吧。各位，我们要转折一下。这是关于这一集的。我引用原话
If you're the kind of person who would like watching a taxidermist, or perhaps would enjoy watching someone removing a splinter from the hand of a small child, then this episode is for you. Well, that's perfect. That is Scott's Tots. Of course, we owe a huge thank you to BJ Novak for being on the show today. And thank you to Jean Stupnitsky, Lee Eisenberg, Paul Lieberstein, and Randy Cordray,
如果你是那种喜欢看剥制标本，或者可能喜欢看别人从小孩子的手上取下木刺的人，那么这一集绝对适合你。好吧，这太完美了。这就是“斯科特小学者”。当然，我们要向今天来到节目的B.J.诺瓦克表示巨大的感谢。还要感谢让·斯特普尼茨基、李·艾森伯格、保罗·莉布斯坦和兰迪·科德雷，
and also to James Carey, who helped me go through some digital clutter. Yes, and Joya Balfour for meeting me for coffee and bringing a trunk full of bobbleheads to me and always sharing with us about what NBC.com was doing. And thank you all for sending in your questions. We love you. We'll see you next week. Love you guys.
以及帮助我整理一些数字杂物的詹姆斯·卡里。是的，还有乔亚·巴尔弗，她和我见面喝咖啡，带了一后备箱的摇头娃娃，总是跟我们分享NBC.com在做什么。谢谢大家发来问题。我们爱你们。我们下周见。爱你们。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. We love you. We'll see you next week. Love you guys. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwulf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubico. is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubico. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial at Stitcher Premium use code OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听“办公室女士”。我们爱你们。我们下周见。爱你们。感谢收听“办公室女士”。“办公室女士”由Earwulf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科。是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《橡树》。有关“办公室女士”的无广告版本，请访问StitcherPremium.com。在Stitcher Premium上享受一个月的免费试用，使用代码OFFICE。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。